the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
the days are back
the church of what's happening now is
thrilled to introduce you
to hellotushy.com
hellotushy.com makes portable devices
that spray your butt clean with water go
to hellotoshi.com church right now to
get 10 off of your order that's
hellotushy.com church
show is also brought to you by indochino
indochino is one of the largest made to
measure men's menswear brands in the
world
visit indochino.com
church and enter church at checkout
right now to get any premium indochino
suit for just 3.89
and that's 50 off of a regular price
made to measure premium suit and
shipping is free that's indochino.com
enter church at checkout
the show is also brought to you by lyft
lyft drivers can make up to 35 an hour
getting started is just a tap away sign
up today at lyft.com joey
and if you complete 100 rides in 30 days
you'll get a 500 bonus that's right
go to lyft.com joey right now and sign
up today
[Music]
all right i got my adrenaline going
kick that [ __ ] mule i got time to
[ __ ] around
it's monday
december 12th
13 days away from the big day
12 days away
from [ __ ] hanukkah
it's the church of what's happening now
mr boss
yeah my little jewish goomba lisa
hello and i'm your uncle joey kick that
muley i want to hear that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
ah
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
are you kidding me or what 12 days away
and you'll be sitting around with your
family with your finger up your ass
looking around the room going i work all
year for this
this is what the [ __ ] i work all year
for to be sitting with these people
these [ __ ] kids i should be the strip
club people's titties on my head [ __ ]
santa
boss rooting in the [ __ ] house
how crazy is that
it's been in the making forever for a
while here yes it has i'm happy you're
on yeah me too man one of your biggest
friends do you have any children brother
i do i have three girls two daughters
a 27 year old she just had a baby
tomorrow he's one years old scott yeah
and then have a 20 and a 15 year old how
many guys did you knock out along the
way
no no you know i did threaten but i
never knocked anybody out yet what a
[ __ ] nightmare is to have daughters
you know i know but it did a good thing
in my school or my in my city
rooting is an unusual name here right so
it has always now always that my
daughters don't say anything uh there's
always a teacher who goes written
by any chance related to boss written
and i go yeah that's my dad oh is your
dad okay guys
can i have your attention watch out with
this girl you know and that solves the
problem that's it yeah
ah but the the the way they connect to
you
and rip your [ __ ] lung out
like this morning there was drama in my
house because she didn't to she didn't
want to say the prayers
or for anybody to say prayers at the
table
so you can't eat do you say prayers if
you eat but go to the room oh she's
three and a half she's gonna be four and
one [ __ ] monkey i'm just gonna all
right so today finally a quarter of the
[ __ ] 10
she's out there praying you know
because my wife goes you're not going to
wear this dress for church you know
we're not going to go to church if you
know she went out there she prayed now i
usually don't go to this church i'm a
[ __ ] catholic
this is some [ __ ] studio city church
a lot of kids
gentiles they walk around whatever
i go today she's in the pageant
oh so i go i put the suit on i bust out
the whole [ __ ] deal my wife's like
what are you putting the suit on people
aren't going to wear a suit i go you
know why
i wanted to know that we dressed up and
made the [ __ ] effort these are the
little things i tell people that you
don't know when you're [ __ ] 20
that you come and go you know what this
is how i gotta act around it
we take her there i
first i parked the car i woke up and
there's my wife i go where's the [ __ ]
kid
she goes they took her that's it they're
downstairs rehearsing whatever the [ __ ]
they do
like all right you know me she's getting
molested in the back of my mind i'm like
the [ __ ] that dirty [ __ ] got
it down there
giving the bill cosby pills rubbing her
feet and [ __ ]
really this is where my head goes i
don't trust none of those [ __ ]
you do know that you have to you have to
you have to because if not when she is
13 and she is telling you to pass the
finger bang that you'll go wow i thought
you were downstairs rehearsing so in my
perverted mind i'm like she's getting
finger banged downstairs but i don't
want to say that to my wife because my
wife's a gentile and he'll break her
heart i go and i play along at first i
can't hear so i get anxiety
in a church they're singing [ __ ]
songs and they're talking whatever
there's a guitar in there with a piano
the guy had to be 90.
boss the guy playing the guitar had to
be [ __ ] nice
i had to get up i was high i had to get
up and look over he wouldn't even he'd
play a chord and he'd pass out
and he'd wake up again and play another
chord and pass out for another it's the
best thing if you're 90. you could do
anything you wanted
to first of all we're in the car and i'm
like you know what
i didn't get hiding hold on i wore the
wrong shoes what are you talking about
i shot out to that [ __ ] backyard and
i blasted off
two pipe fulls of debt
i took some listerine some mint and i
drank some [ __ ] diet soda just to
kill i have no cologne i don't use
cologne and if you're a man and you lose
cologne i gotta shoot chickens yeah i
never use it i ain't meant to do that
yeah you don't take showers and wash
your [ __ ] yeah your dicks gotta smell
like your dick or not that's it so
i run back out i get in the [ __ ] car
i park i run in
i i know i'm reeking the wreath but i
got a suit on nobody thinks it's me yeah
it should look like a gangster too yeah
when you have a suit on you wreak a reef
and nobody thinks it's you yeah i think
it's a kid it took you 10 minutes to
change your shoes didn't your wife be
like oh no no i smoked three bowls in
two minutes
i'm a prisoner of war i'm human i know
how to smoke in quick situations i even
smoked a pipe underwater one time you
understand it
ask me later
[ __ ] uh i get into church i'm high as
[ __ ] boss here uh water is settling in
my ear
it's not coming out so they got me an
antibiotics and some steroids i'm on the
last one tonight
but in a week if i can't hear they're
gonna put slits under my ear to drain my
[ __ ] ears oh wow and it's killing me
when i go to jiu jitsu because
you having back cardio or
smoking too much that your cardio is
[ __ ] up that's one thing but when you
got earplugs on and you could hear your
fat little heart pumping oh don't hold
that pumpkin
and i gotta take them out to listen to
the guy and then i gotta put him back in
and at night you gotta wear these things
at night
okay and i put them on in jiu jitsu
because the sweat goes in my ear oh wow
okay
realize why i feel funky yeah after like
a couple minutes i feel funky about you
what is this
when he goes put plugs in there the
water is settling in there
so
i i can't hear so
it plays out when i'm in a big place and
you have music on now it feels weird so
now i'm in this church and
there's no adults on the stage there's a
bunch of kids singing i don't know what
my [ __ ] daughter is right i don't see
my daughter there's could be the tree
right they got it they got it downstairs
they really cosby that right they gave
her the catholic pedophile smoke that
pedophile smoke
athletes shirts and quaaludes that's
your first thought oh wow dog you have
to go there because if not what the [ __ ]
was my kid
i don't say this to my wife i don't
worry and i can't act like a gorilla so
i just don't say nothing and all of a
sudden a bunch of girls come out dressed
up like [ __ ]
like uh angels yeah and they have little
things like jewish things but they're
long and white i don't know
like oh they were lamps oh that's what
they were [ __ ] lamps okay
no big deal
they come in i i'm looking for my little
[ __ ] angel
and there she is right on the corner
facing me
now you know what man
always people always go that's your
daughter
why because she looks like me come to
the house i got a dog that looks like me
too yeah yeah who gives a [ __ ] people
can look like each other today was one
of the first times i go
that's my daughter yeah and that's why
she scares me
yep that's why i'm petrified you know
why because every kid was at attention
my daughter was doing the same [ __ ] i do
on stage
but what is that i move from side to
side oh yeah you know when i'm on a set
in between takes i st i sit on that mark
but i move from i drive direct this
craze oh yeah and she was doing that not
only that she was at an angle
so basically she was telling and and i
could see that the [ __ ] dummy that
does this that was
too serious about her job he's a
yeah throwing [ __ ] faces
like the four-year-old
and smiling i'm like oh this is director
even my daughter i saw my daughter look
at her one time like what the [ __ ]
and then my daughter looked at me and my
daughter see that i was up there she was
like smiling at me but then she'd pay
attention and do a thing
but the beauty of it was she never
stayed on her mark
she always stayed on an angle sideways
and the whole time she went from side to
side and even when the other kids were
standing like zombos she would move up
with her hands like a real dove like an
angel or whatever oh
i'm like you know what it's crazy
[ __ ] on to something i like it she's
onto something my little flower of love
i don't want to do and stand up
but number one just that rock
got me my heart like it just twisted me
because that's my daughter yep that's it
my mom had the same thing we can't when
i was 18 people always go dog you never
stand still
yeah i have the same thing my people go
what the [ __ ]
my friend who's a dear friend now
when i was
at that age she'd always go
someday you're gonna have a [ __ ] kid
and she's gonna or he's gonna annoy you
the way you annoy the [ __ ] out of people
with that constant movement i couldn't
sit still you know i couldn't sit still
and look i am paying for my sins now
today so you know what it's good you
know you came out good right
not really
i conduct her that's what they call that
conductor yeah they're four year olds
and she thinks yeah you know
radio do it with two feathers you know
make it a happy thing or do something
else yeah lee what's up with you tarzan
you got the suge daddy [ __ ] and shook
nice shirt on today again i gotta
represent the show you want to visit
your cousin in jail look at you oh
no i uh
i i just you know what boss i'm new to
uh this whole world
so i i honestly just spent a little bit
of time looking you up
oh [ __ ] okay
you know what whole worldly
what whole world you know you have uh
mma fight all that
and it was just uh listen you're you're
jewish your people invented this whole
[ __ ] thing
you guys invented krav maga you went and
[ __ ] the chinese people
they taught you kung fu you taught them
krav maga
tell them boss
they did these guys they're under attack
24 7. so they have the best system down
they really have you know i mean the
women go in the army there i mean you
better watch out you know that krav maga
there's some chrome guard gems that like
my buddy uh uh i'm here perez he's
probably the best guy out there you know
he and i i introduced him to the the
guys from sports science right because i
did a few bar fighting things for them
and kicking things and see how much
pounds i can hit and all that stuff and
then they asked me about weapons if i
could do that i say yeah i can do it but
you know i can put you in contact with
my buddy i said he's this guy's gonna
blow you away
and um so i put him in contact i knew
they were gonna shoot around one o'clock
and i got 115 the director is calling me
and i pick up and the thing i say is
he's freaking you out right and he goes
where did you find this guy
you know how i you know how i met this
guy he um i came to america i'm here for
like three weeks of going out he
approaches me he's in a bar and he goes
man we watch all your fights from
pancreas we watch it here on a
pay-per-view uh are you teaching
anywhere i say yeah i'm teaching at the
beverly hills junior club okay so i gave
him the days and he's coming right away
the first day that i'm teaching he's
there so he comes in he watches the
whole class all my students are there
and at the end of the class he says man
that was unbelievable thank you so much
for letting me watch uh can i show you
what i do
and yeah sure you know so he gets his
back opens it up and he gets like a fake
knife out and it's got this this this
wooden gun and and some
i could you know what
i said don't worry about it i said i'll
leave it in the back i'm not i'm not
really into that because what do you
mean i said i've seen it a thousand
times man this is such a dangerous stuff
it needs to be good and otherwise it's
not going to work so that don't worry
about it so he goes okay and he goes
into his bag and he starts looking and
he gets a pellet gun and he loads the
pellet gun and he gives it to me he says
why don't you shoot me if you see me
move
and i excuse me so now the whole class
started what did you just say i said
yeah but he said you got to be you know
you got to be nice only when you see me
move don't point and shoot right away i
go okay
six times six times i was not able to
hit him uh two to connect and six times
he had my gun within
in in a second i'm hit and he has my gun
and he's at the distance so i bought him
in contact with that guy they measured
it two hundredths of a second he took
the gun away if you see it in slow
motion you literally see a redirecting
grabbing the the gun then he hits the
guy in the face as soon as he pulls his
punch back then you see the bullet go
out from the guy who's pulling the
trigger i mean it goes so fast you know
so and this guy
you have a whole bunch of those
there in israel you know the mossad i
mean these guys are high level uh guys
they they're updating it's constantly
renewing it's not a system like karate
or any other sport that you say you know
yid condo that was the only one that was
evolving the whole time because he knew
it was going to evolve and that's the
same with krav maga you know in the
beginning you know you uh
if
there was a certain defense for a gun or
you can't do it anymore because if you
do it this way there was a guy who broke
his finger and then his finger wrapped
around you couldn't take the gun away
you know i go can who finds that out
well they find it out in real life and
then they adjust they make it better
they make sure that won't have never
happened again yeah but it happened only
once yeah well could be your life one
time right so that's the great thing
about krav maga of course there's bad
schools out there as well you know
people ask me all the time about
crafting i said just google you know
google and reviews read reviews but um
you know krav maga worldwide that seems
to me isn't a it's a really good
organization they're on olympic
boulevard right i know something right
down there i always used to pass them on
my way home
the way i send you i think a couple
weeks ago when you were stuck in santa
monica that was it's right there on
olympic right before the 405. but when i
wanted to ask you boss or
like i was watching your highlights and
i was
amazed at all the kicks
like you don't you you just don't really
see that that much now and unless we saw
it last night with cowboy
but
like
why do you think more people don't you
like why do you think it's such an
amazing tool for you that more people
aren't using because you don't i i don't
really think you see that many kicks you
know it was it's first of all your legs
are longer than your arms so uh you know
if i know the guy's a good striker i'm a
better kicker you know so then i just
keep them away with my legs and the
thing is though you need to be
powerful you know i the thing you hear
me say for the last eight or nine years
on inside mma single kicks never throw a
single kick and every we get highlights
from around the world
every single week for 433 shows we did
that people get knocked out because they
throw a single kick you know because
it's easy to stop and to counter right
away so don't do that set it up with
punches unless you can kick really
freaking hard like a mirko cro cup or
like a jose aldo when you kick somebody
really hard to the hat you force him to
defend with everything he's got and that
will buy you a little bit of time so you
can get out of the way for the counter
but if you just throw a kick outside
inside low kick if they stand in one
line like the blading position which i
still told this they can't understand
they do it in mixed martial arts even in
thai boxing i don't get it and in boxing
i mean i always looked at mike tyson but
if they stand in that one blading
line
there's no way they can generate power
with their inside logics so i said why
would you even bother of moving away
from that loki the guy is going to hurt
your skin that's about it he's going to
stretch his leg take the kick knock him
out i mean it's as easy as that but
people all the time they need to block
these cakes you know i
i was with um
george and pierre
uh oh man jake shields jake shields and
george appeared jake was throwing the
inside low kicks but they have
absolutely no power on him and george
every time when he threw him he jumped
back like he let him miss like they were
gonna decapitate his leg i go just take
take the kick take the kick
you know trade it for a ride straight
cross you take the kick by moving into
it which hey look at this i
automatically load up you know anything
you have to do is stretch your arm you
can rotate your upper body you get even
more power so that's the thing with
kicks if you can't kick hard if you can
use your legs well you know and you have
a guy who's better with his hands i
would say use kicks keep him away from
you and then that's the thing that i
noticed is you know
the only knockouts that you really see
with punches are like people getting
knocked out or maybe sometimes it's like
that like they're not protecting
themselves and then the ref stops it a
couple times
in recent memory and on yours they
they're just so hurt that they just stop
like the fight stops they're not knocked
out but when you get kicked in the
stomach they just are in such pain
that's crazy you know my my everybody's
asking me because i'm i'm known for body
shots for the left hook to the body a
left kick left knee i mean i knocked a
lot of guys out with that but the the
way i became a lover of that is my first
time boxing class i got knocked out by
it you know i was a badass karateka you
know black belt came in tore my whole
gym up and then i went to thai boxing
and i thought that you know i was a
badass but against the professional thai
boxer turned out i was not you know and
he started my hands were low because of
the karate was not allowed to punch to
the head so your hands are not next to
your jaw so what happens is as soon as
they hit your head you're going to have
to over commit to the defending because
you're further away from your face so
you have to throw it up with with a
panic reaction so to say but if you do
that yeah automatically you expose your
body and of course this guy being the
professional knew that and he dropped me
right away man it was the worst thing
ever being on my knee never experienced
anything like that but that was okay i
gotta notice you know it's cool i've
always i didn't know this
uh
when i got older no no no no
when i was young i knew this cuban guy
defected
they used to go to my mom's bar he drove
like a car or something
wasn't a big drinker
and one day he talked to me but he spoke
to me about boxing as a science yeah you
know he he was a science
and years later i read something from
bill wallace superfoot
i love him and he was talking and i read
this article about bill
in black belt maybe like in in 70s when
bruce lee you know after bruce lee died
there was this big
phenomenon in this country and he spoke
about it like a science and there really
is
there really is a science to kicking and
punching you know when you go to karate
i went to gojukora you know rashad yeah
uh what's not rashad uh rasad
he's black yeah dad was my first karate
teacher when i came from cuba oh really
told me it's not a small [ __ ] world
that is the craziest thing ever i got
beat up at central park i got stitches
two days later i once showed up it
wasn't all black school
black ghee fist yep everybody was black
he'd make you run the streets barefoot
with the guillotine oh yeah you had to
run by the park where you hung in front
of that's better so the next day when
you went to school those guys were like
oh you're a karate man show us what you
got and [ __ ]
so i went to all those little
tournaments
and you learned this karate but you
never spoke about range no you never
spoken about anything then i got into
whatever i got into i quit when i was
15. and then when i got into comedy
i always knew that if i trained in a
martial art it would help my comedy
so i got into the tank sudo the soup
dough
boulder that's what that was at the time
and it was a lot of kicks
and i enjoyed it
i did it for about three years moved out
he didn't do dick
got back into suboc though
that was i moved to the valley and i was
[ __ ] so i went over here i never
kicked box
they said over here there's a bunch of
great little old schools around here
there's one place of america and i
stayed there for about six months until
i got knee surgery
and i learned a world
like he spoke about things
i had never heard in karate yep but the
guy who really put me over the top when
i lived in hollywood i go over there
twice a week
black dude
earl
him and his brother had studied from
those
the father-son team
that they they're from hawaii japanese
hawaiian dudes
the sun is the host of iron chef
oh wait yes
mark is uh what's the casket
his father
had a school in denver now here i am
living in boulder
uh i was a criminal in boulder you know
and i got locked up then i came out and
got married so i stayed there for a
while and then i started training and
those guys would always talk about these
two black dudes from denver
and i never looked into it you know
there was no computer
there was the yellow pages that were
going to tell you that black dudes from
denver yeah it's not the name of the
karate school you know what i'm saying
what's the dude's name i don't know it's
two black dudes from denver so how funny
is that those two black dudes from
denver have a school number a month
and when i found out i used to go over
it on tuesday when i was 418 pounds you
were 418 pounds i did the longest yard
oh man i was three
ninety when i did the longest yard 380.
well
and that was probably august and after
the longest yard i kept those habits
pastrami sandwiches
i was saying
yeah well how okay well how
what age was that what no what age
started getting that big that i mean
they're foreign
when i graduated high school i was 197
and then
for about five ten years when i got
locked up i was at 2 18. hello 2 15 2 8
so the food was good there no no no no
you know what i stated what i'm saying
to you is i graduated in 82
and by the time
i kept lifting lifting lifting lifting
and i started swimming i moved to
colorado i started squatting i had never
squatted before i always lifted and did
like uh leg presses but when i moved to
colorado my roommates had gone to brown
they were all power lifters
they were eating d-ball and [ __ ]
annavar
and shooting [ __ ] gorilla juice and
[ __ ] but i don't like needles
i would faint i was and i always said
what's the use yeah
so they taught me how to deadlift how to
squat and that's when i really got i
didn't know nothing about that world
nothing they had built all the machines
downstairs
they were like no dead bent over rolls
we don't do curls here we don't do none
of that [ __ ] yeah we do cleans presses
squats and deadlifts
[Music]
they did a lot of isometrics one thing
they did in those days that
uh we did isometrics before and a ton
afterward but they always believed that
coach was ira wolf who was my high
school coach who coached in the olympics
in 76. so the guy was legit
a little dude that went from
he would he was amazing in high school
he would go from d-ball
to hiv
it is so bad for you too man it's it's
so stupid
so that's where i got a little
i went up to about 220 218
and i stayed up that and then i got
locked up and i went to 235 but i was
hitting the bank
i was [ __ ] running i was i got into
swimming before i got locked up i got
into swimming oh yeah i joined the
master swimming program
two classes 5 a.m or 6 a.m i thought
that was it no they don't [ __ ] around
dawg
the chick was a triathlete from hawaii
and she was hawaii so half the year she
would train in boulder for the altitude
and because they loved the sun yeah but
what the [ __ ] hawaii got a lot of sun
too yeah yeah she would go down then
train ocean
so she used to those six months she was
in boulder dog it would snow
okay
because it was outside oh yeah it would
snow two feet of snow they would shovel
a path
from the dressing room to the pool
the pool would just be steaming and
there'd still be 90 [ __ ] in
there
90 [ __ ]
in there there'd be ten lanes
five people are [ __ ] laying and five
waiting to jump in because there's a
class at six
well but she put you through hell you
know she did a oh swimming is good two a
ball between your legs do 20 pulling
yeah and then come back and put the
[ __ ] carry the thing and then do 20
laps a kick and then put it all together
then come back take a minute rest and do
440s back and forth 18 i could you know
it was a man when i walked in there boss
she said let me watch you swim the first
time i started swimming and i woke up
and i hit the wall i said okay we got to
start slow with you and for a week she
made me just go like this and kick
against the wall yeah and she goes i'm
not going to let you in the class until
you could
shoot all the way up she taught me the
exact science of the leg and why it
should be like that
sometimes i jump in the pool and i'm
swimming first two minutes i know i'm
[ __ ] up and it all comes back to
i increased my swim
and i could see how i'm digging still
i see you do that now you know those
moves but it is i somebody told me that
as well i had no clue but it's so much
technique
everything is technic you know what
after a certain age you realize
everything is technique i was on joe's
podcast not this time at the time before
talking about pitching
people who have the ability to pitch
and i learned this at a young age i used
to go to joe namath football camp
when joe namath was in the height of
being joe namath he had a football camp
in new york
did i learn to be a quarterback no but
you always learned one thing and there
was bars ruined let me tell you what joe
look at how brilliant he was
when you walk into joe namath's camp
there was a bunch of white dudes hey how
you doing yeah great to be here you're
like where's joe
and they're like where's joe and they're
like oh wait give us 15 minutes also
they'd line you up boss rooting yeah
yeah here at least i had here joe diaz
here and then joe namath will come out
and he'll give a speech what you expect
from me the whole week but the first
thing they did
and i never followed this two years
later was they make you go to your room
put shorts on a t-shirt and everybody
got tests for the 40. yeah
whether you're a lineman a punter
because i want to show you guys
something and he would test you on the
40 and then after that they wrote it
down
everybody got on the line and the guy
would work with you
i mean from a to z boom boom
boom your step your neck your breathing
your shoulders how they should move he
did that for five days straight
for those next five days monday through
friday from 7 30 to 8. that's all you
worked on
he called it sprint movement
19 [ __ ] 78 for you oh well we came up
with that yeah
and he called it sprint movement he
broke down the sprint the movement of
the elbow how high the elbow should go
up how high the elbow should go yeah i
remember this in the eighth grade yes
the knee the the body when should it
pull back that your thing is like a sale
i mean i can't you know i'm a fat [ __ ]
no i ain't running low 40s
but by the end of the week you made
you're under 40
and you were you would go what happened
yep your time would go crazy did you get
faster no
he taught you technique
and he taught you efficiency yep and the
same is
with everything that's the same with
everything yeah with everything always
get the pro right away man if you go uh
if you want to learn so a friend of mine
always does the same thing he needed to
uh but how you call a yo-yo uh there was
his part he's an actor hulk mcallen he's
got this new show on netflix now he's
going to come out uh mind hunter with um
um
what's his name fincher david finch
really yeah he's doing this show 10
million dollars an episode he's the lead
guy of the actor but anyway he had to do
this
yo-yo thing and he just hired right away
the world champion yo-yo and you should
see him within four weeks the things
that he was doing and i guarantee you if
you go just do a regular joe he's not
but if you have the guy who knows how to
tap into you and to say no no no this is
the reason why you do it that's why i
like enjoy teaching so much i always go
back to the basics and people they say
yeah but it's always the basics and
this example i use many times i had a
guy in my class who stopped me after the
class he said boss you know what's funny
i said yeah
let tell me and he said this uh you're
doing we've been doing the same stuff
for like three years in a row as long as
i've been here i go yeah i say you know
what's even more funny and he goes no i
say you're still not doing it correctly
and he looked at me i go that's why we
have to do it because everybody forgets
the basics but once i go into my spiel
where the power comes from and i show
you uh why why it comes from there it
blows you you go light right away why
nobody ever told me that before you know
but it's just thinking about it and
finding a way to tap in and if you you
know with that swimming
you guys didn't even run probably right
you just did the technique with the yeah
just technically the technical
technique you see and that already made
you better and he at the end of the week
everybody left there i remember being on
the bus home with four of us
me chuckie mcbreen
and his brother and we go how
that's amazing everyone in there 4.9 who
the [ __ ] knew what it was that
and all of a sudden you're 4.75 or
something you're like what's that what
happened yeah he taught you how to run
and i remember going back the next year
and i beat it again
i beat the record before
because he gave you homework to do he
goes do three of these you know it's
just really uh so with pitching it's the
same thing
if i pitch right now and it's 32 miles
an hour
once i go to the pitching guys i'm going
to go hold on let's do these exercises
real quick warm up the eye loosen the
tendon you have a tendon back here that
if it's not loose yeah it takes 10 miles
an hour off your thing meanwhile you're
sitting there like [ __ ] what happened
to my arm and almost it'll go with the
technique again and how it should come
up over your ear and all that stuff and
that's where you get your power from but
the power still comes from the hip yep
that's what we're talking about that's
still you know and then it's this hip
yep yeah the opposite head it's the
opposite hip for baseball how [ __ ]
crazy is that because you're throwing it
back
yeah so i'm here
and i have to lift yeah unless you saw
our man louis tiant
over there in boston he turned his whole
[ __ ] body around yeah you know that's
uh
blind laver you know that guy
left yeah he's dutch he's a he's a dutch
pitcher here he's he did very very well
yes very well yeah i heard he's in the
hall of fame so yeah that's cool they
had this
five years ago and i felt so horrible
about everything they they uh the the
best uh uh
male athletes from the netherlands and
they
they put me on number two and i felt
like there's no way like the soccer
players you want crive everybody was
behind me like a gold medalist you know
i felt so horrible about bear blind
laver he's the pitcher he was the number
one guy apparently he had an
unbelievable career yeah we don't have
uh in home we don't have that we maybe
have three clubs
baseball yeah maybe now more but it's
never been big and hard now i'm going to
ask you simple questions
but i just don't [ __ ] know that i
want to ask you
in holland why is it
well so well known for the kickboxing
there
i never knew these things i've just
heard a little and you gotta make
believe like you know oh really you
gotta make a little line why is it wait
because we just had guys
it started with young plus young plus
was from mango gym had rob came and all
these guys at the time milliwell gobley
i mean they had a team which was an
unbelievable team they would go to
thailand and they beat the tice and
everybody how is this possible what they
did they tied the hands together with
the legs the ties at that time and still
now a lot you know they
mostly kick each other back and forth
back and forth back and forth now since
that whole thing started happening at
rumble deckers once he started going to
thailand just destroying people it was
because he has great hands and legs and
he tied them together smart they're one
of the most famous guys ever right in in
in thailand he was also a wbo boxing guy
he had that also he had the hands and
the legs together so we grew up with
that we i remember a show we had with
the rob came and it was a big rock game
and fenced down he's a good friend of me
now of mine but we had to show there
were four world title fights in holland
that they broadcasted live
to thailand we fought uh four world
champions in thailand they all got
knocked out that night in holland i mean
that never happened again they never
wanted to repeat it for some reason the
dutch really liked their striking but
you know with us you have soccer skating
but you know after that's probably thai
boxing i mean every week there's fights
everywhere so people just enjoy punching
kicking i guess
so that's i thought that you were going
to tell me well no back in the viking
days it was his
i love all that type of stuff you know
that type of like you know the sky went
developing now you said something before
you said something about a lower leg
kick is it a lower leg kick and a higher
leg kick no no no just a
a low kick but you know some people what
they do nowadays they kick also below
the knee
you know which is you know could be
dangerous if it like for instance
yeah because there's the tibula you have
the fibula tibialis the tibialis is a
little thin bone i might flip it around
right now but anyway that bone can be
broken you know i think uh pitbull fairy
you know he
against benson henderson when he got
kicked there he broke that bone okay and
fight was over now my stance is a
different stance like i'm standing right
in front of you so if i lift my leg if
you kick me a loki you're going to get
my shin you need but if i blade if i
stand in one line with both feet yeah
then they got a nice little cushion
there which is your calf they can kick
around another great thing for that is
of course balance if you kick lower on
the leg of course you're gonna
move this guy you know so like you see
john jones also using it you know it's
it's all very smart you know you bring
your opponent off balance and if he's
off balance he can't counter he might
counter but not with a strong punch so
you can capitalize on that i always
thought that
you know on paper
i don't want you to think i'm [ __ ]
crazy on paper i thought the old school
kenpo guys were really good at that
of going in but before attacking the
body they would throw a leg kick a very
inside kind of
an explosion like kick to throw your
attention off and then get your 15
[ __ ] times
nobody really does that
no there's not a lot of
great there's a lot of good strikers but
great ones they're uh they're still hard
to find but you know it's like anything
else
you know yesterday uh charlo and uh what
was it uh molina that uh was it no no
there was a difference anyway there was
a boxer there also molina i know his
name is molina but you know he was very
wild to me he was very wild so there's
always differences in just in in
anything some guys are just they win
because they have a lot of heart they
can take a lot of punches a lot of shots
and they have great stamina and they're
very hard to beat you know but when you
see them they're not as technical as
other guys and then you have other guys
like in uh lomachenko i don't know if
you saw him uh three weeks ago box no
dude he's probably the best boxer out
there right now powerful pond i barely
have enough time for [ __ ] the ufc you
know i i caught a half a fight of
bellator and i almost jumped out the
window because i don't know when the
[ __ ] bellator's on yeah bellator is like
uh
like uh one of them remember the other
we've interrupted your television
that's bellator to me i never see
[ __ ] boss people always say you watch
bellator last night what is it on friday
saturdays i don't know so i barely got
time for the ufc what was today sunday
whatever
how much football that was today
stumming yeah that's how much fun well
we don't have time for that anymore it's
just like like i haven't for 50 20 years
to get serious you yeah you're gonna
have to give up something to give some
things up yeah
yeah boxing i grew up on duran and uh
benito uh alfredo benitez and all those
guys you know aaron pryor you know
life happens and you lose then i got
back into it when tyson
you know i lived in a coke dealer
tonight tyson locked out the guy with no
teeth brother leon springs brother oh
yeah we were all pissed off because it
was going to go 15 rounds i could rob
him steal some more rocks and [ __ ] they
went [ __ ] 10 seconds
there i was i was done
leon i met leon in the ukraine a good
guy very funny yeah everybody this is
really funny yeah it's funny you can't
you almost can't understand what he says
they said you know if he's drunk it's
actually easier for him hey man what's
wrong with you with that yeah yeah it's
like almost like yeah what the [ __ ]
james brown
like everything he said
but uh that's you know you it's not that
you lose interest it's just
your computer has so much [ __ ] uh
what's that one people what's the term
computer
drive there's so much [ __ ] space you
gotta say it in english because
apparently that works for apple if it's
english accents it's smarter your hard
drive only has so much space
and it's there and you remember it but
it's not really [ __ ] active you're
trying to pay a house you got a child
you got a career you're working on you
got to write jokes you're trying to
write this you're trying to write that
so
i love sports it's just when the [ __ ]
you know i forgot the ufc was even out
last night you know i did uh i just
started with with morrow right we have
the router manelo show but we just
started like this is number five we had
yesterday
we is the combat sports carousel so we
talk about all the fights this weekend
and about the fights coming up and then
you realize
how much work it is i mean i have to
watch all these fights i have to break
down all the fights from next week like
this week there were three boxing shows
on and then you have the ufc on friday
the ufc on saturday there's bellator and
there was glory kickboxing and we talked
about everything so i'm gonna you know
your family live in the weekend it's a
very hard thing because you're gonna
have to watch
you have to watch the fights otherwise
you can't talk about it i can't sit
there for that long my back i gotta move
the great thing is you know once you
record everything you can fast forward
through the openings and all that stuff
i got 45 minutes
i got like 45 minutes
and i gotta get up and walk around and i
can watch something else again and i
gotta lay on my stomach for a while i
can't no more those days are over what
you need what you need is you know and
uh and and i have no clue why that we
don't see them as much anymore but i had
one of those glasses when i went to
japan even there was like around 2003
glasses that you hook into your player
and then you can you you watch tv it's
like you have this giant screen in front
of you because it's against your eyes
and you can just watch tv so then you
can watch it everywhere now with netflix
on your phone you can you can sit
somewhere at the doctor's office you put
the shades on and you can watch [ __ ]
glasses on the right bus room hey listen
you can watch anything you want the last
thing did you see a report that came out
with thursday on world news tonight
crazy people are going to [ __ ] die
yeah but don't drive a car i'm just
saying lazy people are going to [ __ ]
die oh of course binge watching you're
going to die they were saying that
you're gonna die a young [ __ ] age
it's bad for you i always believe that
shit's bad for you
you don't want the least glass i don't
want to watch dick if i gotta put
glasses on and connect it to my phone
that's why i don't smoke uh
what's that [ __ ] they smoke with the
stone like i got a blow torch at the
house dabs
that's too much commitment
that's a little too much commitment you
know what i'm saying rolling papers weed
the lighter i'm in a pipe
once i gotta bring a blowtorch in to do
something for my
for my
how does that work what do you mean is
it like dabble like shatter or what how
does that do you make a stone each other
how do you smoke shadow you know it
depends what you have there you have
these pants right you have the
yeah that's an easy one but that was the
stone i never heard of that right
there's a stone
our friends that uh nailed it life
nailed their life our brothers i love
those dudes but whenever they show up
they show up heavy dude they don't even
smoke weed no more
they break out a stone and it's like a
piece of wax paper you think you're back
in the 70s and you're [ __ ]
the old old old-school cokers
used to use wax papers and [ __ ]
and you know it's like this [ __ ]
thing and they blow torch the thing and
you put it on top of that and then you
have to hit it with a [ __ ]
a straw
and hold it
way too much work what did we do you
were there that night when your head
almost blew up when desiree was there we
walked out of the improv yeah we smoke
it how did we smoke it i thought that
was just a regular dab rig with like
they had like a little torch in the car
i've never this one this one i've never
tried seen this this one sounds good
that was the one
then it's so good that i forgot about it
yeah that night we i remember i hadn't
smoked
and i went in there i was trying not to
smoke
and i come on they had dabs i swear to
god
about rooting i thought i was gonna die
speaking of dying this was the last
start that oh my god are you serious so
it was a big week you know what i'm
saying it's the this week just started
well give me a little i'll take a little
piece off
it's 12. there's no way i can do this
12 days till yom kippur you know what
i'm saying i got at least saying
i would never that one's got a tail
that's how much i love you lisa what's
where's tony bennett [ __ ] don't make
believe like you don't know what i'm
talking about
oh yeah
[Music]
so
[Music]
look at poorly
he's about to puke you should have seen
his face oh yeah we had like what 12
stars gives a [ __ ] it's the lord's day
jack
i could not do i can't travel
i'm like
i don't can't spell my name
perfect yeah perfect that's how you want
to travel anyway who wants to listen
traveling and being i can't fall asleep
on a plane because i have sleep apnea
but on jet blue mint
yeah i could plug that [ __ ] in yeah put
my little gas mask on and [ __ ] yeah i
believe i'm in auschwitz
and i just passed yeah oh i love this
thing your cpap right it's the best
thing ever right
i have one too i mean on a plane yeah
i'll bring it oh no but i don't use it
on the plane because if i set up
straight i won't snore i don't have the
problem but man it's i sleep much better
you get all the air i love it i almost
can't sleep without it anymore i love it
because i know
when i spoke to joe he said talk to you
but i did it already i don't want to
hear no details about blood and [ __ ] i
mean no surgeries you have
you know um i had
only two but but you know because
i was i was just the first time when it
broke you know you go to the doctor and
then i put it back in but no a big
surgery was only once actually because
they really quenched my nose and uh and
then
i was sitting standing in front of the
mirror putting it back because it's
before i'm teaching a class to these
kids in holland and this guy comes and
he says what's going on but you know i
said i broke it i just push it back
because what the doctor is going to do
anyway he says well if you want i can
change it for you we'll never break
again
like what do you mean he said well
that's i'm a surgeon i do noses and
everything you said we can put so by no
see it's it's a plastic nose now it's
it's not plastic it's a different kind
of stuff but um you know it can't break
anymore you know you can break all the
way on the top but that would be that's
a very hard thing to do you know to
break your nose but since then i never
broke my nose again so it actually works
it's the crazy thing you have no idea
what's going on lee's face is getting
rather redder by the minutes and he's
going to be he's looking at the numbers
and they're turning into different
things right now
he's making believe he's keeping it
together but he's breathing out of his
nose
he's blowing out of his mouth not only
that's our favorite for me my little
brother yes sir
i have to do something that's going to
be very deep right now okay i have to go
pee but i have to go downstairs that
means those stairs coming up
i'm going to be a [ __ ] so i
might feel you down that might be about
five minutes okay
i'm contemplating just taking my little
helmet out and peeing off the balcony
but i love my office i can't disrespect
you i'm saying
professionals don't disrespect
don't get me wrong i'm taking my credit
card i'm gonna see if i still have my
burglary skills and i can break into
this bathroom
if not i gotta walk down to the first
floor keep
boss rooting occupied he's got questions
for you okay okay give me some questions
all right sweet let's do this you hope
you wrote it down i did i'm just still
working up there now no it's not working
yeah
it's so funny
been there done that this is yeah this
is no
i've been doing it for years with them
so i'm actually okay all right
did you ever have an issue making weight
the greatest thing with me is i uh uh we
had no weight less when i was fighting
so i'm actually the first ufc
heavyweight champion right that title
and it was because there were no weight
classes and once they decided that that
was in 1999 it was a four-man tournament
and it was going to be 200 pounds and
under and 200 pounds and over oh i
actually for the title fight was 197 so
i had to gain weight i had to drink
waters at the weigh-in i would go over
200 pounds otherwise it wouldn't be a
title fight
and but that was it so i never had that
problem if i would fight now i would
probably fight maybe 205 or maybe what
85 i think
that's an easy cut for me i mean i'm
walking around 210 so i'm walking around
like i've always been my entire fighting
career
is that what you recommend because it's
it seems like there's been a lot more
recently
uh uh instances of fighters missing
weight that i haven't seen in the last
couple years and so it so my questions
don't really work anymore but what i was
going to say is like
what do you think it as a fighter
what do you how how do you how do you
respond how do you think you would
respond if you were told your opponent
missed weight like i'm i was almost i
was kind of surprised that max holloway
didn't put up more of a stink it didn't
seem like it like that three pounds i
don't know how much of it it doesn't
make any difference it's not a
difference you know what you know what
how i would deal with it it's it's it's
a better way to go mental on the guy and
what that means um if somebody for
instance will be three pounds over you
know uh i would say yeah keep it you're
gonna need to do it i'm uh i try and
really freaking out keep your three
pounds don't worry about losing them i
think to me that comes over it's way
more intimidating first of all then when
i say no no i want him to go back in the
in the sauna right now i want him to
lose the three parts to me that it seems
like you're scared right yeah and matt
max holloway is somebody who's
absolutely not scared no i mean we had
him on a show and it's like mcgregor you
know it's it's 100
convinced he's going to beat everybody
and
and and he's doing it so that's why
because he's such a badass he didn't
care that's that i wanted that is i i i
forgot to write it down uh but that i
wanted to talk to you about his
confidence because
you know he he opens up his post fight
interview talking about jose waldo which
i think is a hysterical but b
like just to go to have that kind of
balls and i'm
we've we've discussed for the length of
the show how i'm not that kind of person
and i
i want to know what
makes a person have that much confidence
like is it is it just something that
people are born with or it's just crazy
to me to have
that much confidence no it's it's it's
not overthinking things that's the whole
thing with everybody if you're nervous
you're overthinking things it's if you
you know it's all in the head and if you
say okay i always tell my students if
you can fight
in the fight like you're doing in the
dojo like you're sparring
you got 90 for sure you're going to win
this fight you know but
doing it under pressure it's a whole
different ball game suddenly so so you
know for him
he
he performs the same in the in the gym
as she does when he's fighting he knows
that so he knows he fights at his best
abilities and then he knows you know if
you let doubt going into your mind it's
like when they ask me um
what are you afraid of a millionaire
both in your prime who would win i go i
i would win how would you win i said
i'll beat them up and they go
well that's that's a big claim i said
what do you want me to say you want me
to say yeah you know what yeah
that's a big chance that you can knock
me out you know i think as a fighter you
can never think that you should
to yourself you should be treated she
said no i'm not going to lose this fight
whatever happens i'm pretty sure he's
going to say the same thing to me back
having doubt in the mind you know if you
plant the seed just before that before
the fight that you you say to somebody
yeah you know what i yeah i might lose
because he has a really hard right
straight you're probably going to get a
hit with the right straight punch that's
that's how it goes i think as a fighter
and any athlete you know
the example i always use that kobe
bryant
you know let's say he's standing for he
has to shoot one goal and if he hits the
goal then his team wins it's the last
move of the of the whole game and if he
misses the team loses that's a lot of
pressure and he can score that thing a
thousand times but with all the pressure
you know now suddenly you get affected
now he's one of those guys also who can
put it to the side and then just scores
it's uh you always
when we were young we always heard
people
our age now say you know what i could do
with what i know now oh yeah you know
all the different situations i was in
that i could have
uh
done a lot better with my mind yeah you
know by controlling that you look at now
and go what the [ __ ]
was i thinking yeah where was my control
or whatever and
it's even how i look at jiu jitsu now
the first two years of jiu jitsu
i started over here but then i couldn't
go at night no more
and then they only had two classes
during the week so if i had an audition
on tuesday i wouldn't go the whole week
because i leave on thursdays to go on
the road
so it kind of sucked on me so i was like
what am i gonna figure something out
so i started going down to higgins on
mondays and wednesdays i saw him
yesterday actually two days ago great
guy yeah that guy great guy just it was
a small class in the daytime his actions
at night
so again i was going one week i was i
would go twice one week and then i
wouldn't go for a whole week because i
was on the road
it was inconsistent i started going over
here again but they didn't want to do a
daytime class it was just a holiday so
they were like you know what we'll come
in on mondays and wednesdays and [ __ ]
around
and i was getting into it the guy's like
listen after this week we're not gonna
do it no more
and one night i went to do comedy at
flappers
and i saw alberto crane school and i go
you know what i'm gonna walk in there
and at first i was scared then i went on
the schedule and i saw and i went in
there january 4th and i'm still [ __ ]
there it's going to be a year next month
and you know what i go twice a week if
i'm in town
three times if uh if i'm in town i go
three times a week if i have to travel i
go twice yeah and i don't go in there to
choke people out but the whole problem
i've had is okay
so you're going in you go through baby
steps and you know your weight and your
age
but the real problem was i couldn't
breathe so i had the nose surgery
and that gave me a little bit more but
what i really needed to do was how to
breathe again yep so i read dr belisse's
book
she came in did the podcast and she
contacted you no i think you and her
would make a very insightful team no
that would be great because when i
discovered uh
i don't want to [ __ ] it up here
then
the inspiratory muscle trainer the
training i'm a little [ __ ] up right
now i have my glasses on
inspiratory you don't want me to tell
you what i saw
you don't want me to tell you what i saw
i saw something completely different and
you were talking about
the
boom we were talking about before yeah
yeah yeah
oh what did we say
diaphragm diaphragm used to diaphragm
your coastal muscles everything it's so
funny that you gave me exercise and that
was the main thing
you know when i went in i could hold my
breath for [ __ ] 20 seconds
that's embarrassing yeah listen let me
explain something to you buzz
for me i know listen i smoked [ __ ]
weed since i was 13.
i smoked crack for about six or seven
months then i quit i went to el paso and
i couldn't find no crack
so i just went back to snorting
everybody was happy you understand me i
said [ __ ] it i smoke crack out of a can
what do you think my lung looks like
yeah yeah yeah because my wife didn't
know i was smoking cracks she thought i
was smoking cigarettes and reefer but i
wouldn't make believe i was drinking
soda and i'd crush up the can and put
holes in it yeah and just put the crack
of moon down there and light that
[ __ ] up like i own the living
room and [ __ ] lead you know my wife said
to me we were talking the idea
this producer whatever the [ __ ] he was
writing we were telling his writer
at starbucks [ __ ] marie t and my
wife is telling them she goes i remember
time
with the sleep apnea at first
i had sleep apnea i was 400 pounds
i was doing a grammar blurry night
right well and then whatever you would
give me like if you had anxiety pills
i would try whatever i was like mikey
you don't remember me you didn't grow up
in the 70s there was like commercials
here for
what's the night cereal
the shittiest cereal out there
that tastes like gas
and they would even go this isn't for us
my friend no no
it's even worse i like raising bread
when you go to prison you like you got a
certain urge for raising friends
i'd say you like fruit loops before you
go to prison and [ __ ] like i won't eat
raisin bran go to prison [ __ ]
you like the raisin bran real quick and
[ __ ]
then you learn to pick the raisins for
later yeah and just eat the bread you
know i'm saying and then later on at
night when everybody else is eating
their fingernails you got a bag of
raisins you want a dollar fifty there
you go with a cigarette
a cigarette
not me i didn't smoke in the joint i'm
just saying that
uh that's what they're going yeah
everything's a cigarette tacked onto it
yeah man you can't hit me up for a
cigarette too you want to eat [ __ ] so
there's like money there cigarettes huh
cigarettes are like money cigarettes and
money yeah gambling things you know sell
for cigarettes yeah let me get that
t-shirt let me get 100 cigarettes wow
it's a currency in a way yeah even if
you don't smoke yeah
even if bots don't smoke no it doesn't
matter because you know don't get high
of your own supply right that's the rule
i would have 20 months
and my [ __ ] uh in my little stash
prison i had like two cases i had
marlboro
and something else marlboro lights or
something
and they would go for top dollar but i
would cut great deals with a pack of
cigarettes i owned you for the month
yeah
don't worry about the book
was like name brand worth more like if
you got a marlboro was it worth more
than like a handmade cigarette
you know
like i said it was
uh boss when we first got in here we're
talking about criminals you know we're
talking about his friend god bless his
soul
and it really uh turned me about bars
because
you know i always thought bars was a
law-abiding guy
by which he is but by him telling me
this he lets me know he has a heart he
understands that mind you know you grew
up around fighting you grew up you not
that you grew up you fought in japan
where that [ __ ] just the yakuza is
the best in the world
some people don't like that element at
least for you to say he was your friend
so we're gonna yeah let's [ __ ] yeah
yeah
it's funny when
i got locked up
when i went to my final destination
it was like i had been there before like
i felt right but it took me like three
days
to get into the swing you know it took
me like three days to talk and a couple
new yorkers to say hello to you there
was no cubans
but a couple of mexican guys talked to
me
one guy from new york was very nice but
there was one guy from philly
that was particularly nice to me you
know big [ __ ]
tats
good looking dude you know
white
kind of reddish hair
had a weird look to him i could tell he
was a junkie maybe at one time but now
he was lifting weights and stuff
just spoke from the heart and there was
another fat italian dude in there
that you look at them two minutes you
know this guy's in there for extortion
or something yeah
he was in there for something
but nobody [ __ ] with him he was just
like goodfellas
he had his own little hut and then there
he had a setup and a half like a kitchen
like he had no roommates
i just thought about that right now my
buddy i was talking about same thing he
had a fridge in his room yeah he called
me from his room with a cell phone
oh no we have floor heating right now
this is 1988
there was no cell phones we had a pay
phone that you have to put corners in
that type of [ __ ] at that time
one of the guys figured out a way how
you to make calls
with no change again you got to go to
him and go dog yep my mother's dying in
the hospital let me make a call it's
going to cost you [ __ ] come on
don't do me like that five cigarettes
nah because it's an endless call it's
unlimited you know what i'm saying
you're going to be on there crying and
then they start [ __ ] i'll give you
10 minutes and [ __ ]
let me get 50 50 cigarettes
but he had the corner pay phone that he
would put in those days he had there was
four pay phone right in front of the
administration building so he could
watch you
and the bell would go you had 20 minutes
that's it and the bell would go off
he even had it beat that it could go 40
minutes oh well or 60 minutes so you can
talk to your friend in italy for 60
minutes
but you would have to give him three
cartons of cigarettes oh hey
like that type of [ __ ] like but he knew
some black kid figured that but he could
only do the corner phone yep that was
the problem not all three of them
because it would be tremendous he'd be
running the [ __ ] place wow
it's funny how people come up with those
things right they're all there's always
a way to break the rule or to to still
or to still escape you know in jail and
it's still it's still happening i mean
last week it happened again right people
break out you go to how is it even
possible bed sheets no time together i
go like that
and you know that they're either going
to shoot you or
they're chasing you and the bad thing
about
we live in listen man
i tell you what
i think being a kid just came to a
[ __ ] end
i saw a commercial and now you could tap
the car
you can what
tap the car just put a little thing in
the car oh yeah it'll tell you the
distance if it pops out who's got it
excuse me where it is blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah it's not
gonna be fun to be a kid no more doesn't
it tell you like uh an alert if they're
speeding yeah everything everything yeah
no it's number two you're okay listen
there's no
i couldn't have done half the [ __ ] i did
30 years ago today
not even close because all my [ __ ] was
walking around
there's cameras everywhere yep and guess
what buzz if you don't think this is me
and i'm a dumb [ __ ] i got a ged okay
if they find the body right now
on lancashire
and magnolia lee you're an intelligent
guy you went to [ __ ] school for four
years
let's pretend they find a body there
they find blood
and there's evidence that it happened
right there on that corner okay there's
no possible way
that that body got transported stabbed
somewhere else and dropped there to
throw the authorities off because that's
going to start happening
isn't there any way i could go
you know
all right give me all the cameras in the
area that's one thing give me all the
security cameras there's a starbucks
what i'm talking about right there you
know what i'm talking about machine
magnolia right there magnolia and
lancashire
there's a starbucks there's a big
building bento box
right is that where that is lee yeah
yeah there's they they have one of the
officers
the oscars do that thing and they have
that
italian pizzeria on the corner so i
would get the camera from the italian
pizzeria and the starbucks and where
city city [ __ ] burnt down your
favorite place [ __ ]
is the italian pizzeria you're talking
about dominoes no yeah well there's a
dominoes there and then across the
street there's the place where the
sangria is nine bucks and the pizza
tastes like gas but there's always
outdoor seating yeah pit fire and the
only reason why you go there is because
the [ __ ] theater with that shitty
theater upstairs
that's the only reason why they're there
it's a [ __ ] nightmare that whole blog
across the street there's a chicken
place black place tremendous there's
always a line first up they got four
tables why do you have four [ __ ]
tables
let's go get a loan let's go get one of
these black va loans yep and put 10 more
[ __ ] tables in here there's always 30
people waiting my wife went waited
online
thirty dollars for six pieces of chicken
and it was men's um you click on the
popeyes yeah and it would have been a
lot better you may got a whistle and
dirty rice and everybody wasn't [ __ ]
happy
i never read the popeyes ever
but the thing that really like the
italian guy i'm telling you about
he was in there for some federal mafia
thing
i never asked him he never told me
i just asked one of the counselors and
he told me
and but the funny thing is
most people cook
to sell food in there he cooked for
himself he was the real deal
he did he did gambling sheets
and i became friends he kept watching me
and i would get one sheet from him and i
would gamble with him and put the bets
in and then you go you want some nachos
like nachos
who has nachos in prison he had nachos
oh wow and one of the best nachos i've
ever had he'd melt the cheese with the
inside of an iron
you have an iron like this and you take
over here and it becomes a rod
and you take a piece of american cheese
and you put that rod in the middle and
you gotta leave it there for like eight
hours
and then he would cut the chilies and
the peppers
and he cut a bunch of [ __ ] and season it
up and you go in there four o'clock he'd
be staring at [ __ ] for monday
night football oh the whole place smells
great he was the king man this guy had a
pot
he made soups that's not a godfather
isn't that when they went with the razor
fellas
there was this mexican dude
that his mother would drop off
300 burritos
on sunday
and he would sell each one of them
and i would buy 15
green chili [ __ ] burritos how many
cigarettes was that
i would just blast them off cash
and i'd run them an errand once a week
which meant
that
when i had my you have store privileges
this was a prison camp
so you had store privileges
if you had higher up numbers and you
were just about to be released
you go to the store once a day for 20
minutes
at this time barcelona what do you think
you're dealing with joy bananas
first off i did something nobody even
thought thought of doing
there was a chinese restaurant right
next to the [ __ ] place
did i tell you something
it wasn't that bad it's like every other
chinese restaurant outside new york you
just got to get the right stuff on the
menu yeah they make the right stuff
that stuff was low main pork
if you got dry noodles
with some mustard and [ __ ] damn
football you were banging on monday
night football
same thing i would get the chinese food
he would say what are you going to do on
monday who's got all this on monday
night nobody me
monday nights i would always get ice
cream
and sodas
and i would take it to the hiv place the
hiv place had a couple dudes in there
but the hiv place had the best
television in the house
and they had the best living conditions
and all of them were in bedrooms coffee
so i would go there bring them ice cream
and soda and then let me sit in their
living room and i got these other black
dudes this other white dude from
cleveland and we count our [ __ ]
gambling money and then nobody would say
no nobody would say nothing to us
it was like a [ __ ] movie you know it
wasn't moving yeah but here you know
i was in charge of the stock room so i
could hide [ __ ] for people
so boss rooting wants to hide the gloves
he's got two sets of gloves he fights
you know if people come in here and they
want to fight
boss rooting takes them in the back
three dollars a ticket
boss rooting throws me two dollars to
hold the gloves once a month
so that's how i would make my money oh
well guys like you would come to me and
go hide this for me because it was a
well-known fact that you could search
everything else but the dogs never went
to the back stock stuff where the cans
were yep
so i would hide gloves in there you know
there was dudes that were just drinking
steroids
and i knew all of them because they all
stashed their [ __ ] on the pallets yeah
joey please let me stash my shutter
palace they would put little packages
the syringes were up their [ __ ] oh
yeah i mean
this was crazy it's the craziest thing
and they had spare syringes which they
rented out or gave to you but for
cigarettes or whatever they'd walk
around with two syringes in their
[ __ ] you listen uh this is a funny my
buddy right there isn't uh
a big
bug
dude it's so it's so dangerous also to
to share start sharing nils especially
in a place like that but this guy he had
like he was the steroid provider to all
these bouncers at the
casino no i used to work you have no no
but he had like the six syringes ready
right all all filled up already and then
this these these bodyguards the the
bouncers would come in one by one
and they would drop the pants he would
throw it in blue put pants up and it
goes out so this one guy walks in uh
pretty big dude he gave he gives him a
shot the guy passes out oh no what
happened before also is that this was
going to be the last guy he was going to
inject so he already put his own pants
down so he was going to do himself right
after that and of course the guy drops
he catches the guy he stands behind the
guy now the owner walks in and they're
both standing there with the hands
underneath
oh
yeah try to explain that but no no it's
not what you think really okay it really
looks like it's what i think craziest
thyroid story that i lived with he's a
dear friend of mine
i haven't spoken to him in a few months
i gotta call him tomorrow
uh dear friend of mine since i was kid
since we were kids
and you know he went away to the army he
became the soldier he i mean you know
this kid was crazy came from the
neighborhood but he always had something
boss you could always tell when your
kids there was something about him he
was very sweet
he went away to the army and then they
had the big right up about him he ended
up going to the white house with regular
[ __ ]
you know he saved three [ __ ] dudes
whatever the [ __ ] the story was
then all of a sudden i see him at the
bar he asked me if i want to do a blast
i thought you were in the army yeah i
got thrown out but
you were the soldier of the year they
gave me a medal
who knows no
three months later and his brother's
listening to this podcast
the one well
anyway one new year's they got into a
fist fight and this kid bit my friend's
hero
they're both it's like if you bit lee
zero right now plus what happened
bit the bottom and had to stitch it up
today everybody's friends and
everybody's family
what the [ __ ] was that going to tell you
what the [ __ ] are we talking about i got
to stop eating these talking about the
guy
in the army he got discharged from the
army you know there was a fight going on
with his uh brother or with his friend
you know bit the ear off
but there was a [ __ ] point here boss
rooney
oh steroids oh it was about steroids we
grew up together and there was a time
when
i used to buy guns in colorado
jump on a plane
bring the guns to his house get off the
plane in newark bring this 1987 bring
the guns to his house oh my god he'd
have a buyer for the guns then give me
that cash and i'd buy coke and then take
the coke from him and take it back to
colorado now i'm a [ __ ] kid i'm a
[ __ ] dummy okay but i got balls to
steal and i'm a dumb [ __ ]
so this goes on so it was always a deal
when i got off the plane
the plane landed at 11.
i had to be back at the airport by three
all i wanted was my cash coke and his
mother had to make chicken cutlets
because i lived in colorado nobody knew
how to make italian chicken colors with
the mashed potatoes and the creamed corn
and the [ __ ] cranberry juice nobody
knows how to do this these [ __ ]
gentiles i don't know how to do that
[ __ ]
the one time this is like my fifth trip
now i grew up with these guys
now i was bringing them nine millimeters
every week brand new with the holster
with the i mean
like john farooq you should have seen me
right out of miami vice
i just show up and you'd have like three
of your [ __ ] goomba friends with you
and i'd walk in the room take my winter
jack and go
and have the whole holster
with the gun in it with the two miami
vice clips
and the whole package would cost me six
and a quarter and i'd bang them out for
[ __ ] 12.
and then i'd buy the for uh
9 800 you got 11 ounces
this is 1987.
i'd take two out throw four in and bang
them out at 18 16 a piece i was living
like a doctor doing nothing i could
still snort my ass off because i
wouldn't lose yeah i wouldn't lose i
just love the image
because you couldn't fly with the
holsters could you on your body
no they were in my luggage yeah so like
i just love where would you go and put
on the holsters for this presentation on
the drive from the [ __ ] car you know
what i'm saying listen you can't sell a
ten thousand dollar product with a ten
dollar presentation you know what i'm
saying
drop that drop drop it on your lisa yeah
so the one time
like every week was a new adventure
every time i went to the house and i
loved them daily until today i love them
every week was a new adventure the one
time i brought mushrooms
fresh from colorado that were killing
[ __ ]
we put them on the table in the bedroom
giggling and we hear potato chips
what the [ __ ] is that noise in the
living room his cousin his little
brother has eaten the mushrooms he
thought they were frozen mushrooms oh
so that's one time this time i walk in
the best scenario ever
this time i walk in i'm like where's d
he's in the bedroom i go in there
he got a safe
on top of that safe there was two tears
there was one tier that was just
filled
with little
d-ball
bottles
vials i mean in order
like this was
this is 1980 [ __ ] i got knocked off
an 80s
this is way before 80s this is
86.
the whole bottom shelf
was just one ounce vials of d-ball and
the what was the the one from germany
the one that [ __ ] yoked you up like a
[ __ ] diana no diana ball was the
shootable
this was uh
annabelle no hanover rips you up this
was the one that [ __ ]
from your wrist up
like once you did it from your wrist up
jack
that growth hormone no no it was a she
was a pill oh wow big in the 80s big in
the 80s big in 82
real big in 80s what was it those uh
things that they gave to cows right for
the asthma or those that i think yeah
yeah crazy
lee from here up the muscle would start
here
three months you would get muscle here
people go what the [ __ ] are you doing to
your wrists i'm doing push-ups and nice
and magical yeah don't make me smack in
the [ __ ] mouth what do you think i
just followed them i grew 23 pounds i
walked in there the bottom of the top
rack was the juice the bottom rack was a
couple packages of powder and cash
his pants are dropped
he's on the phone
the cord from the wall
okay he's got it like this
he's bent over about to do a line and
his mom's about to shoot him with a
[ __ ] steroid oh
you can't write this in no nobody's
gonna believe it yeah bro he called in
we had him call in ten times he's one of
my tight buddies i gotta call him
tomorrow i'm mad at him because he
didn't show up to a gig and i saved that
seat for him i could have gave it to
somebody else as he bent over
he shot him
and he would do a line of cloak and she
would shoot him at the same time
that's taking it to the next level
that's 1986 north bergen new jersey not
my parents
no
wow then she ended up taking one of
those guns and shooting at him one time
they missed his head okay oh no this was
a real house this was no drama house
this was no [ __ ] abc
blackish or back from the boat whatever
that [ __ ] chase
good night mom good night son good night
they look all up and down everybody that
would be funny you know the brady bunch
you see that screen with all the little
screens and all of them are doing drugs
oh man
that's hilarious
you've had a very interesting career man
yeah and it's funny just to answer lee
another thing you were talking about
pancreas i just recently watched like
maybe one or two pancreases
were there a lot of wrestling in
pancreas i mean was that no that's why
you were throwing that many kicks
you know you know i i always got taken
down um
because yeah but the thing was you know
if that was the you know i always
enjoyed when i was inducted to the hall
of fame last year they made these stats
thank you and and i didn't know any of
my stats i didn't know that i i had a
total time of four hours and 27 minutes
you know they do all the stats all of
fight time four hours 27 but another
great stat was that i never attempted a
single takedown yet i won 14 fights by
submission so i thought that was a nice
little thing so that meant that they
took me down and i was able then to
overcome that but yeah wrestling has
never been my strongest point it's a
it's a super important
aspect of mixed martial arts i always
say it should be the one in the middle
you're either a really good wrestler and
a striker or a really good ground guy
and a wrestler but for some reason in
holland it's very hard to find wrestling
schools it's not like here in america
that everybody does it so i figured you
know what i'm just going to focus on the
ground and maybe
maybe that even helped my ground game
because i think if i would have been
great at stopping takedowns my ground
game wouldn't have been
as good as i it is right now because you
know i had no takedown defense listen
before we proceed you're a sweetheart of
a guy
plus that you could kill me with one
[ __ ] knuckle if i'm looking at you
and i giggle
i am not high and you're not the devil i
am laughing at [ __ ] all behind you
because
he is going you even hear the song by
ozzy osbourne black sabbath i'm going
through changes
yeah
that's lee right now
he's really going through changes right
now
every time if i'm looking at you and i
look off the side it's not that i don't
love you yeah and said he's going
through deep changes in this damn he's
thinking i'm not going to change i'm
watching you evolving i can't speak
anymore oh my god you have no idea he
just had a little conversation with
himself for about four minutes
about college and tuition i watched the
whole thing go down look at that and
meanwhile you're talking to me and i'm
like nobody
can't believe this show how many stars
we
deep
we started with i think eight but then
we had the chocolate
i have no clue hiking today yeah that's
a lot i did
i didn't get anxiety coming up the
stairs
you see it relaxes you out it doesn't
it's that the [ __ ]
inspiratory muscle yeah oh the trainer
i told you it's gonna help you i saw you
talking about it like
this has been listen
uh there were times i could drive home
and go you know what because of my
breathing i'm gonna have to give up
jiu-jitsu
it's embarrassing
and then i go home and i go [ __ ] that
noise
i'm going back tomorrow and then i'll do
some hip escapes
and then i'll warm up that really helped
like i go in the back and i'll just jump
rope and i'll do kettlebells and by the
time i get on the mat i'm warm and then
the class we do drills and by the end my
breathing isn't that bad
i have to just focus on breathing in my
nose and out my mouth you know once i go
off that pattern i'm [ __ ]
and the anxiety raises
so right now i'm in the process of just
breathing if i get last
if i can go five three five minute
rounds
i'm [ __ ] happy yep i'm very happy you
know plus the workout plus the warm up
before plus i stay for mobility class 15
30 minute class afterwards
that's all i need i i'm still too
embarrassed to bring the piece in and do
it during jiu jitsu i think i don't want
it on the floor yeah you don't need it i
don't want people's feet on my [ __ ]
tube no then i'll get my fungi toe and
my mouth and i have fungi yeah they're
not gonna look good that's a
[ __ ] right there we go try to
explain every one of those swords on
your lips oh yes yeah no but i
i you sent me
the uh
of the trainer the
no the the disc the trainer how to box
and stuff like oh yeah yeah yeah okay
but the the one worked on my computer
but the other one was doing something
it's not your disc it's a [ __ ]
computer i'm getting a little one for
christmas oh okay so once i get the new
one for christmas but i started
uh
experimenting you know you gave me the
exercises in the chair
i started doing those
and then uh
i just started doing squats with it
and then push-ups
i started doing uh
you know like uh
chokes like from the closed guard by
myself and then i started doing uh
uh what do you call those things not
triangles but when you [ __ ] the other
one when you go to the side from the
when you're on the bottom it don't
[ __ ] matter yeah the the old is crazy
and i got it down this is the best i've
done i don't know what number that is
this is as well again it says that we're
number seven okay that's pretty good and
i get dizzy sometimes not real dizzy i
just hear like
but i hear that noise a lot whenever i
get high i hear that noise hey japanese
people yelling you know
it's a bunch of it's so [ __ ] up
what my first panic is like when i first
go on the yard i warm up i stretch my
back
i uh do some push-ups i do some sit-ups
by the time i get up i get the jump rope
and i'll jump rope for maybe 30 seconds
and that's fine
then the next 30 seconds
forget about it my world goes [ __ ] as
[ __ ]
and then i'll push it i'll go [ __ ] this
and i'll get back on and get back on it
and then maybe i'll increase it to 33
seconds but i'm [ __ ] running out of
gas
then i'll wait 10 or 12 seconds and i do
it again until i feel myself
kind of like joey hold on one second you
could die
and then i breathe myself through it and
right away my body goes into panic so i
gotta pee right away
there's times you know i've taken my
dick out and peed on my ghee and my hand
and [ __ ] because it just explodes yeah
the anxiety goes out that way that is so
crazy it's the weirdest thing when that
was 418 pounds
i used to go to justin fortune's gym and
macca foley would train people in there
and the first or second time i went i
peed myself in the ring because i
couldn't breathe just the anxiety of
seeing stars after [ __ ] three minutes
and just
movement we were just moving we weren't
even boxing yeah
you know and then i realized i gotta
start bringing two pair of shorts and i
gotta wear underwear
looks like i'm going to be peeing myself
a lot now
first three months with nakafoli i would
pee myself
three times a [ __ ] week you know wow
but you know what i wasn't breathing
correctly the whole time
if somebody would have stopped me and
took the time
to breathe correctly it's so weird now
i'm working with this
i stretch out my rib cage
i mean in my [ __ ] marathon in 44
minutes no but guess what
the first time i roll
i gotta stop at the two-minute mark
and rest for like 30 seconds then i
finish out the thing
then the second one i go a little longer
then the third one i'll go a little
longer
and that's my class you know what i'm
saying like after that i'm pretty
[ __ ] happy yeah after that i feel
like i'm gonna [ __ ] pass out anyway
i've done enough anyway you know
i don't want to be able to
i gotta know how i gotta learn how to
match my breathing up the whole
mechanics you know we're breathing the
the great thing from this is it will
teach you automatically to breathe a
great if you do a small hole on there
like at the number 10
and you breathe in you'll force yourself
to use your core in your diaphragm okay
so tens a little smaller yeah but you
can only do breathing exercises where
you don't want to train with that you do
this exercise i sent you on the chair
right like breathing in and that you
will actually feel your diaphragm
feeling yeah oh yeah i feel it now yeah
see what i used to happen was this you
ready
there we go
and then right there we go
and then right here it would just go
boom because there was no muscles yep
there was no muscle to control that now
hold on
hold on
yeah
yeah
you're breathing now using your
diaphragm that's it
just that
is already that's you see that's just
that that's the same as what you were
talking about in the beginning with the
running with the elbows not too high
it's just that that's it you know that's
what i got forces you to do it the
correct way that's the great thing about
it
so on your own you kind of i spoke to
you through it which is very nice of you
you know man
one thing i've learned about jiu jitsu
and the world of jiu jitsu his people
are very kind
yep
after you choked me four times
you just people go you know what
let's learn that move i'm catching you
because obviously you don't see a cop
yeah
there's nobody who shoots you and then
shows you how he shot you yep you know
jiu-jitsu does that jiu-jitsu is the
only sport that people see and give you
a t-shirt
you know when you sent me this thing
when you sent me the little [ __ ]
booklet and stuff it what meant the
world to me because it's health yep you
don't give a [ __ ] this ain't for money
and you're doing this for help you
thought this was
and i always get uh inspired by that
type of [ __ ]
people like really you got you know
somebody a friend of mine called me one
day [ __ ] my friend says he he knows
some fat man jiu-jitsu he wants a
teacher
i said you're killing me he goes no go
on youtube
it was sent you're real and [ __ ] he was
a great guy matt baker came down i own
my world he taught me through two things
that i'm great at yeah a different type
of side control that [ __ ] ain't
going nowhere you know saying like [ __ ]
like that
when it comes to health i got the utmost
respect for people
because people are always trying to do
something
i gotta be careful yeah two weeks ago at
the
at the helium comedy club in portland i
was smoking pot in the green room the
alarm system went on fire the electrical
system went down
the lights turned off they came in the
room
but it did not the fire department came
but they said what somebody was smoking
in the green room and the management
goes yeah then they just left
and turned the power back on but that's
why i wanted you on here i want to thank
you personally because a lot of people
don't every they do everything as a
[ __ ] angle yeah yeah this is a really
great health product man this is a
[ __ ] great and i started on my desk
in between computer things i'm sick and
tired of sitting there
i did this special
and since [ __ ] march i've been
sitting there yeah an extra hour every
day that affected everything it affected
my back
so i realized maybe i should do
something in between whatever i get a
good idea maybe i'll do 10 push-ups
maybe i'll do a down dog for three
seconds you're not gonna i can't do no
real down dog i do a [ __ ] up down dog
yeah yeah a little half down yeah like a
half down dog but you can do that also
with the other two what's your [ __ ]
yeah try this this is why yep this is
why you know what sometimes it's a sunny
day i even yell at least sometimes i go
you leave the [ __ ] house yet
sometimes i take the baby to school i
come back and go in the yard i smoke a
little bit i said that for five minutes
but you got work to do you can't sit out
in the sunshine you know what i'm saying
the sunshine don't pay the rent i ain't
no farmer
so i go inside now like when i'm sitting
there i move my ankles and i do all that
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] to keep your legs
alive
but now i'm doing this i do a couple
push-ups a couple sit-ups i thought it
was great man i wanted to congratulate
you you know it cured me from my asthma
it's it blows me away it's the most
important thing in your body is oxygen
i mean you can go three days without
water three weeks without food three
minutes without that
you know so and everybody's focusing on
food and being bigger and doing and
drinking and whatever you drink i go
let's focus on the number one priority
here because if it's that important i'm
pretty sure if you increase that
then you're going to feel much better
you know so that's that's how it started
i came up with it when i was 14 years
old when i i had asthma attack like real
asthma attacks i mean a weak in bad not
able to eat you know because i couldn't
breathe using inhalers
well when i came out with the prototype
within uh i think six weeks i was cured
i never had asthma anymore i sent it to
my buddy in hollywood as asthma he's
selling them right now in europe because
his asthma was gone in eight days i
start telling people you ask me i say
listen i cannot medically prove it yet
but we we were getting very close now uh
i have like 18 medical journals coming
out and where it's proven what it does
for you i mean usain bolt's using it i
mean the the the gold medallist in the
olympics three other gold medals that
you i mean it's getting really big i
just cannot release anything right now
because i have not enough stock so
that's why we're just slowly building
and then once you know i have 20 000 of
these things in stock
yeah then i'm gonna say okay here are
the medical journals here here's all the
proof that you can do but i never carry
an inhaler anymore for my every single
title fight i had every fight i had
when warming up your lungs will close
like that happens with pretty much every
asthma patient you have to open them up
with albuterol and once it's open you
can go now i don't even carry an inhaler
with me anymore that's been i've been
carrying inhaler with me for like 48
years everywhere i went
everywhere i went always needed one in
my hip bucket
he's still alive
lee is still moving
he's
he's still going to change his whole
life i'm not going through changes
and you know people still call me festas
by the way i you know what the worst
thing is now take take take two slices
of bread it's gonna work much harder
also right what do you mean well if you
just took a star right and you wait 15
minutes and then eat two slices of bread
what happens you never did that no oh
dude that will intensify the whole thing
immediately if you guys eat a burger now
hey hey boss in 40 minutes you're
freaking out you don't need to tell him
these things
he doesn't need any more tricks
so i come in here with a loaf of toasted
bread and butter tomorrow
you watch you eat it you wait 10 minutes
then you you you take it you wait 10
minutes then you eat that's the trick
it gets into your system right away
that's what i did with it i've heard a
thousand different
a friend of mine used to eat medical
marijuana [ __ ] only with pizza
with extra cheese because the cheap the
cheese does something
that's you know you can do it anything
it's a
[ __ ] buffalo and somebody gave me a
job papaya enzymes which i love
and guess what
i've been eating papaya enzymes in 1981
ever since i started selling coke
because i used to go to the coast to the
thing to get the inositol
then that's at all that's it that's uh
it slows you down right inositol is the
really really good cut back in the 80s
okay you know joe weeder
yeah yeah joe weiner used to have a
[ __ ] thing called
something fat it was the original fat
cutter and it was chlorine and inositol
that was his claim to fame
inositol in the 80s was what real people
were putting in coke it was untraceable
it was so funny that
when i first started buying an announcer
it was six dollars a container and eight
months later it was 35 dollars because
even the farmers just got hit
so that you were cutting it with a coke
like two
two [ __ ] ounces of 35 [ __ ] bucks
i [ __ ] you the [ __ ] of course
and that's why sometimes we did a lot of
cokey go i lost weight
wasn't the coke it was the [ __ ]
inositol you dumb [ __ ] yeah plus you
know you're sweating it out
oh it's just the worst oh
yeah
fast routine every november
this year would be nine years since i
did cocaine
nine [ __ ] years and those last three
years
were brutal
like brutal oh you so you still say oh i
should try it one time me no no no i
mean
i think so
worthless drug
let me tell you something right now for
me to do cocaine
it would ruin everything yup just on a
even if i never did it again
it would break a promise i made it would
ruin it within
a week i think i'd be done something bad
would happen
i mean like a personal personal problems
that's it then you got to do it and i
never missed it after that you know once
you're clean from something a while
you're like wow i can't believe i lived
that long thinking
i couldn't be alive without this thing
and now you could be alive without
anything once you realize that you're
like [ __ ] this ain't [ __ ]
you know it's it's all everything's in
that man every everything is trainable
everything is habits everything is like
me now now i go to new york i take a red
eye i arrive there like five o'clock
a.m and i'm gonna you know sleep maybe
hopefully four hours
but no problem not ten years ago when i
was still drinking
you see then you walk at the airport you
go you don't know where you are you
gotta look everywhere you know you lose
your tickets you got to fight it again
and like the stress you have and then
you realize when you just stop that
you go like hey i can drink a beer here
and bring beer there but you know to go
tanked again before every flight and go
on the flight and you feel like crap
when you you know you start thinking
you're getting older we're getting older
we want to be a little bit more healthy
you can do much more
in the time because time is the only
thing we can't have more of right
it's funny how some nights i'm in my
living room or i'm in the office trying
to write jokes or
trying to write a paragraph or a book or
whatever i think about
like i was writing about a certain time
in my life
saturday night i had to stay in i stay
in this week because i was on the road a
lot i shot this
it's just i knew i had to do early
morning radio this week so i had to go
to bed i had to east coast radio and
they wanted me to call it the first
[ __ ] pencil i got was if you're
calling at 8 30 uh
new york time i'm like that's five
thousand
which guess what
bus route and i'm up
if i don't have to get up
are you with me oh i know exactly what
you mean so let's say tomorrow you go
joey can you do my favorite call into my
show at 6 a.m yeah uh whatever and 9 a.m
new york time 6 a.m you'll be up i see
you on twitter [ __ ] around don't lie
to me come on just call me okay but
guess what
tonight i'll go home i'll be home at 9
30.
i watch tv i'll smoke a bowl
and i go [ __ ]
that's right i gotta call my brother
buzz let me go in and lay down
11
12 15. yeah
one o'clock yeah
now you're in a [ __ ] deep zone now
you gotta do something hey you want to
be fresh the old days guys like me and
you're like [ __ ] it oh get up dog get up
yeah right let me do ten jumping jacks
but now you know that that day's gonna
be a [ __ ] as it is never mind
you [ __ ] it's a night that's what
happens to me yep that's whatever i get
four hours of sleep
i can't go back to sleep after uh bosses
call for some reason now even though and
now your whole day is not [ __ ]
it's uh now you know why these older
people they wake up so early though
everybody wants longer time it's the
thing one thing that you don't have you
know i can't call my parents at 6am in
the morning they're up you know but
getting up there in age and i think
truly believe you know if you want to do
something if there's a lot of work to be
like my friends they say yeah but you
know what i would say oh the trainer i
got to do these 30 repetitions anymore i
don't have the time for that it takes it
takes about four minutes
say yeah yeah but i wake up later i say
wake up four minutes early it's very
simple you know like in the morning i
wake up early because i before everybody
goes to school i already want to have my
things done i don't turn on my phone in
the morning i wait till that till it's
like 9 or 9 30 if you try to reach me
too bad you can't reach me i don't go
online you know i do the things that i
do for myself first and i my whole and
then my day starts turn on my computer
and i start doing everything and if you
don't do that this is the biggest
problem the freaking telephone all the
kids walk on the street i was i was in
new york two weeks ago i'm walking on
the street and it's 80 percent of the
people are looking on their phone and i
mean it's not 50 50. it's you look
around everybody's on their phone nobody
has time for you they break up
by text they start dating by text they
do everything by text sexting whatever
they do yeah i mean it's the craziest
thing these phones are the mice they
they really are they know where you are
what you spend what you do they know
everything about you and everybody's
hooked to the thing you should stay far
away from it you know if a few days a
week if you can say okay you know today
just be between one and three or one and
four you leave the phone at home you
know maybe maybe take it with you turn
it off you never know if you're going to
get in an accident or something so you
have somebody that you can call but turn
the freaking thing off my daughters you
know when there's uh where we're eating
we're having dinner and then somebody
texts and they have to respond right
away i said why why do you need they can
wait 10 minutes yep
they think i'm angry
well just tell them from now on if you
don't react you know you're probably
eating done that's problem resolved but
no they have to immediately respond to
those texts drives me nuts if we go to a
restaurant nobody's allowed to bring the
phone anymore i bring my phone i turn it
off i put it on
what is it on airplane mode so we can
make pictures but that's about it
you know social media is a big vehicle
and what we do uh
i have twitter on my phone and i have
hotmail
and that's it that's it this is very
smart
i have periscope
that's a good one too yeah facebook live
is good
you know facebook
facebook
i don't know some days
it's interesting
some days it's just a cry for [ __ ]
help some days yeah some days it really
aggravates the [ __ ] out of me
some days i don't even look at it it's a
sad day if i see a quick somebody family
from the church family
i'll put something nice to try to make
that day to see if they're having a
shitty day but besides that
i look on facebook sometimes i go what
the [ __ ] is this
what is this why am i looking at this i
could be writing a half a joke yeah
looking at a character because y'all
ain't got a [ __ ] word or something so
that's what i get
from the
from the social media thing i don't let
it really cut into my [ __ ] that's why i
keep my stuff lonely lean knows
when people come to me with new gadgets
listen i got what i got and i barely got
this yep the last thing i need is a new
[ __ ] what's the gradual this is
better than periscope because you could
talk to the people and you could see
where they are and you could charge them
two dollars like listen i don't want to
do that yeah yeah yeah i just want to
pop on periscope when i want get the
[ __ ] off there when i want i don't you
don't have the [ __ ] time to be around
there all day i try to go away from
social media saturdays and sundays i do
too okay so i disappear friday morning
and i get back on there sunday night
sunday night especially if it's a
business week you got to get on there
sunday night to promote to let them know
uncle joey's coming to town slinging
dick and giving out firecrackers you
know what i'm saying yeah [ __ ] it
you missed doing the mma hour
oh yeah yeah that went on for how long
nine years yeah i i do miss i miss the
people also uh
you know you become a family you know
you know these people for nine years
every every week you see them
you know they become they become very
close friends so yeah i missed that
that's uh it was always fun i never had
a day in my life that i
said you know what today i i rather stay
home than do the show i always wanted to
do the show it was always fun to do it's
always good to have guests on the show
maybe like a mcgregor i met him through
our show you know so we get the new
stars on this is two years ago but you
know you you also the old guys sometimes
you talk to coleman or to to dawn fryer
dan severan you know
they come back on hanzo gracie then then
the new young guys again that i don't
know you so this way it was a way of me
for me to stay in touch with the old
guys but also to get the new talent and
start knowing this
these new fighters that we have nowadays
so it was funny because
when i would get off the stage on friday
nights i would get back to my room
whatever city i was on
and either you were on or it was coming
on in 20 minutes yeah you know what i'm
saying if i got in at one like if i got
in at 12 40 and you weren't on i knew
you were coming out at one yeah you
didn't come out at one we got a problem
but you know what there's a soda
fountain downstairs and they got potato
chips like all this isn't killing out
and that's how i would watch a few
things
you know me i at that time i was still
to this day
since the ufc really broke my mma cherry
i still watch the ufc if i have to
very seldom well that's why i said i
never know when bellator is coming on
and the other places i don't really
the other people i don't watch i don't
even know what else is out there maybe
the world series of
an amber alert did you get that too yeah
yeah she made it my mind lived up to
this way i stole my cat
what the [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy when that happens
now every cop is looking for you yep
what a [ __ ] nightmare to be a
criminal full-time now oh my god
it's so useless eventually they all get
get caught you know you're gonna do me
and jail that would not be a good thing
man i don't uh i'm not a happy person
when i'm locked up you know i want
freedom i want to run around i want to
scream do crazy things
that that would not be
what losing your freedom is to you lose
your freedom no i believe it and for me
it wasn't the freedom part
i've said it a thousand times it was
more
the slight looking down from the guard
to the convict
that non-respectful
they respect you not that they respect
you
they keep it light
because they know at some time you can
blow up the [ __ ] floor
but they still have this weird treatment
of you
i always told lee you don't know what
your life is until a man kicks your bed
and tells you to wake up
that does something to you can you
imagine that mother come to your bed
just kick and go wake the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah eventually you're gonna get up and
choke me
eventually yeah i would not be with that
that's not good no that's not good
nothing authority figures i'm not a big
fan no nobody putting a light on when
you're sleeping
is very [ __ ] nice then they kick the
bed
then they say something to you yeah i'm
saying and there's nothing you can do
because if you do they'll have another
place for you
they'll go sleep here you know right
in the hole or whatever and they gotta
sleep with stitches and a tube up your
ass yeah
so
you know the system you already know the
system they never beat you
they never make believe they find heroin
none of that [ __ ]
but they always play
that hand like they got you
and they really do have you so who are
you kidding who you know it's uh
so now you start playing
i'm not doing nothing
but even if i was i could you couldn't
get me
and you start playing i know you're
doing something
you're a criminal and guess what
nine out of ten
i'm gonna get you yeah and that's what
happens now in the system
and you see it go down
and sure enough this guy goes for one
week
the way lee's about to get leak you're
getting sleepy
you don't need to tell me that
you're getting sleepy we put your head
down it's okay it's not being i'm not
asleep
you know what listen
listen no man deserves to go through
these changes put your head down
it's okay i'm not gonna be mad you know
your family i'm bad close your eyes five
minutes just take a breather
it's not being you everyone remember
when you're in kindergarten it's not
being no no time it's not being here
you cross your arms like this indian
style right
oh
that looks really good look at the way
look at him
yeah sitting over there going through
changes you're hearing the people
yelling
changes sweaty god
you don't know what i've seen boss
rooting it looks like
he's got virtual reality glasses on and
he's got
but he's not looking because his eyes
are closed the lights are turned off and
he's listening to apocalypse now that's
how
that's uh what if your face looks like
like well yeah that's what happens with
1800 milligrams whatever we have
who said it was 1800. it was at least 14
hours stopped lying to these [ __ ]
people how much was it
a lot
don't ask questions all right
i've been doing fine
about rooney you ever look at these guys
in the ring and you go i miss fighting
every day every time you know the worst
is if i go to a gym to interview
somebody and they're sparring
you know they go like oh i wish i could
do that i don't want to take the risk
anymore i have four neck surgeries like
a plate for the front four disc fusions
back i mean you know it's the time that
you
you start thinking you know what i'm
gonna give my body a little rest i beat
it up enough i did enough crazy stuff in
my life and
you know i got the crazy stories to pack
it but that's it it's time now to
to pay attention to life right
i mean it's out of control time again
here we go again time everything is time
and
this uh
living walking in pain i rolled like
when i saw higgin i was with another guy
also and he wanted to roll now i didn't
roll for 10 years there's a reason i
don't roll because i have no coverage on
my kneecaps which is extremely painful
not at that moment i can do it but the
next day and
boy the next day yeah i look at my wife
and go oh man can you even walk the
stairs anymore you know it's because
it's aggravating the knees start blowing
up
so it's not fun anymore that was the
reason i stopped fighting people go like
why why did you stop you were still
winning i said well because the training
it was hurting every workout 10 times a
week in intense pain
you know get my tendonitis in my arms
kill me you know i was losing weight
because of the pain i couldn't eat it's
um it was not fun anymore what you know
before all that training was fun getting
tired oh i love getting tired i i
wanted to get a status uh
as much as possible because you know for
some reason that would give me a great
feeling
you know i learned how to love that
that's what with things people say i
don't like training i'll learn to love
it how do i stop you know otherwise it's
not your profession if you don't enjoy
it you're not gonna go far you're really
not you know you need to love it and i
think once you fall in love with it and
there is no pain
well sky sky's the limit
i mean you're 51 years old now
you could probably probably still knock
a lot of [ __ ] out
and still wrestle
but i think let me tell you what happens
i think when you look at the tape you go
i'm not doing that no more
no i'm a different guy now also you know
the things i did you know people
you know i've always been very nice but
you know to a certain point
and you know you have these guys who
suddenly think that you're afraid of
them you know when you when you say hey
listen we don't need to fight here you
know and then you do it again and you do
it again because why would i want to
fight it this guy is not going to be
anything to me
but now he starts thinking that you're
afraid so now he turns it up and then
always this conversation goes like dude
i hope you're not thinking i'm afraid of
you you think i'm afraid of you
i'm afraid to beat the crap out of you
that's what i'm afraid of because i will
do that there's no way you're going to
win this thing so and all that you know
i in the early days when something
happened i was right in there you know
but of course i was nice i was nice
again third time that was it now i got
much more control now i can let it go
for seven times you know and then really
i still walk away until they put their
hands on me you know but that's that
hasn't happened a long time at 15 years
nobody
ever did that so and i'm really good
with talking as well i was a bouncer in
holland and the reason i was a bouncer
was because i nine out of 10 times i
solved the problem you know without
fighting and that's why they wanted me i
was wearing my glasses at the time i was
wearing glasses as a bouncer but you
know i just talked to everybody and just
hey what's going on here and then once
they hear once they explain themselves
what the reason is they're fighting they
realize it's really stupid because it's
always stupid you know and then you say
are you are you kidding just think about
that and i give him a beer give the
other guy a beer fight will be over now
if somebody would keep pushing
you know then i wanted to make sure that
everybody was going to find out about it
so i then i would just go go to town on
the guy because i would set an example
then people go like yeah he's really
nice but you know the last time we saw
that he was headbutting the guy like
five six times in the face you know like
because i would do that on purpose
because the headbutt is a very
for people when they look at that
they think you're a complete psychopath
and i know that so you know then if
somebody was a really bad guy like a guy
had an ashtray in his girl's face yeah
now you
you're gonna get five headbutts you know
and that that doesn't look pretty for
people who are watching but that's a
different guy you know also when i
realized i was
you know the my my wife said it she said
could you do it i said oh no i'm uh you
know yeah if they attack me i go all the
way again i don't care about that but i
was just a different person you know you
you grow old like we all do and you
start thinking about life you go like
huh yeah i i would i would solve that
problem probably different right now
i'm talking about
last week
i was talking to roger he showed me tape
on bernard hopkins unbelievable this
guy's turning 52 in january
you know
okay he's the same but that happens i
became a fan of
and the thing i've always liked about
bernard hopkins
is what earl
i can't remember his name is the guy who
taught kaiju kimbo
down here uh and how that i told you was
the casket student okay his main
philosophy is
why am i blocking you yeah
why am i why am i wasting
all this [ __ ] time and blocking you
let's just do this
let's just
make believe i'm moving
and you're missing me
yeah and his main thing on his style
which i can't remember now
it was kaiju kemba where it was
something they called it something else
which you know there's a thousand
[ __ ] names
was basically
uh it was evasive
it was all based on range
and it was all based on
not getting touched i remember when i
would have conversation with him he'd
always go i never see ufc fighting
that they're really cutting in angles
like they johnson
like that
that's a karate guy right wonder boy
thompson right he's got great distance
great distance distance man is the most
important in fighting always anderson
silverham also great yep great distance
great distance yeah so uh eyes on your
opponent and uh and the distance that's
it they're either too far away or
they're too close it's very hard to
fight at the just perfect this just
outside the range of your opponent so
you only have to move back like half an
inch and then right away you can counter
again if you can find that that's the
thing that's most of the time you know
that happens with fighters when i start
a fight you will see my hands are low
and i do this on purpose because i want
him to hit my head you know and then
every time i let him miss but every time
when i move backwards it comes i let him
come a little closer and i'm just
getting used to his reach and suddenly
i'm
i'm like half an inch out now i found
the switch you know that's a really
nice way easy way to figure out
somebody's switch you don't want to
figure out if you fight a guy like john
jones with what i see 86 reach you know
if you didn't spar with somebody with a
long reach they'll knock you out with
the first punch i mean the difference is
insane i mean he can literally from this
distance
but
from we're sitting right now he can
probably hit you he can knock you out
now if you're used to my reach
you know and then suddenly have that
that's a big problem so let him throw
some shots
you know figure out the reach and then
figure out what you're going to do with
it it's a game
it's it's weird how people at home watch
fighting
especially now with the explosion of mma
and it's got so many different avenues
how people these guys make it look easy
and even boxing and they all think they
can do it yeah they all think they can
do it and it's so weird how i go to
lunchtime jiu-jitsu
but at least once a month
the
daytime guys are talking about the night
before
how a guy came in
said he never did jiu jitsu before and
he armed by the purple belts yeah
because
during like drills armbar purple body
was i thought he never did jiu jitsu
before oh no i learned how to do it on
youtube
yeah it's uh
well i i learned watching both videos
and books that's how i learned with the
body of mine and then finally after a
year training a fighting in japan i had
no sparring partners i was training on a
bag and then i found one guy and then
you know after my last loss i said you
know i'm going to have to change this
i'm going to need to
know the ground game otherwise i'll
never be anybody with this and then i
started training and i never lost a
fight anymore but i took it to the next
level
you know it's again you want something
well you're gonna have to do it a lot
and once you start training two times a
day or three times a day every day you
know and being busy with it in your mind
and writing down all these crazy
combinations you come up with you know
yeah everybody can do it it's just
finding the love for it
you know i i still can't believe that
you have fighters out there
which they will tell you before you
fight them uh you know you know that if
you get them on the ground you probably
can't submit it right i go that's that
should
this guy should be disgusted with
himself can you imagine you're that guy
or you know you know if you hit him to
the body he'll probably go down he
already went
down five times to the body five times
that will not happen with me after three
times i guarantee you that i'll i'll get
so angry
one time two times maybe but third time
i don't want that to happen it's not
gonna happen you know that's that's my
call i'm gonna do everything in my power
to make sure that's not going to happen
and by the way i'm going to counter that
now please come for it i'm going to find
every counter everything that i can do
with that special body shot but if i
don't fix it why are you why are you
fighting that makes no sense if you
don't want to get better yeah but he
onboard him again well he's in this is a
dumbass you learn the game you know it
makes martial arts guys that was in the
early days
you know you have these strikers but you
knew if you had them on the ground boom
you won and then and vice versa of
course you know why i got so much better
at comedy
mma
oh yeah well i can't say i'm a man i say
ufc
i'll tell you why because
i was just getting um
i was just becoming acquainted with it
and i'd put on the countdown or i'd
watch the fights and they'd talk about
who was coming up next and they'd go
back to their backyard and they'd show
them doing all this [ __ ] and also like
all right in my mind i go i'll bet on
that guy and i'd always lose by myself
i'd always get my ass kicked in the
early ufc's you know
what the [ __ ] are we talking yeah
because you look at bodies you you look
at the person how they look yeah you
know if you look at a guy who's uh
jolted up full with the
with reuts you know as a normal person
you're gonna think oh he yeah he's gonna
win and we were talking also about the
people at home how how they think they
can fight because they see you don't
even see that
is the is the funniest thing ever last
time i got an uh somebody said oh i got
the
i got a new opponent for cm punk and he
showed me a fight from a guy who was
very wild
and i go like how many fights did you
have this guy is actually fighting how
many guys how many fights did you have
for posting that video
i mean to me that guy who's in there
deserves a lot of respect winning losing
i don't care you know they're doing what
they want to do
you're not doing it but you're talking
about it because you think you can beat
them these guys can't do anything
it's a shame it's uh it's it's so easy
but by a boss if i hit him in the head
his body opens up and you can go for the
body right yeah why is nobody doing it i
said why don't you fight
why don't you try that out one time i
had a student
and he was 38 when he started and he was
a bodybuilder power lifter 250 pounds
and the first day i told him i said
that's got to go all he says what i said
at least 40 parts of muscle need to go
because this is going to hold you back
it's got it and he's 205 fights at 205
right now
he's now 44 had already like 12 matches
you know one nine so he's he's doing
good never had aspirations to become a
champion he said before i get old i want
to try it i want to know how it feels
to step in there so he did it that's it
full mma full mma god bless you but you
know what he said in the beginning he
said okay so if i'm on the ground right
and sidemount i can knee his thighs
right i say yeah why is nobody doing it
i don't know maybe because of them
because it's super effective okay yeah
okay i said but you know what just wait
till your first fight
then he comes back a week later hey
standing i can do the two right knees to
the thighs what if they do really
freaking hard i say yeah that's how they
should do it but they don't you know
yeah that's why it's not effective i say
but just wait till you have your first
fight and then it comes with another
technique and as i would say every time
i would say
wait till you have your first fight then
his first fight came right
and this guy is
like all technique is gone and the one
combination that we worked on so many
times you know was a right hook to the
body keep looking down to the body like
he thinks it's another body shot then
you hit him in the head
that one thing came back and he knocked
the guy out like that but for the rest
it was a horrible fight so after the
fight he said what did you think i said
what were the knees to the thighs
in the standing position and on the
ground now where was i got a crazy move
and he looks at me with the blanks there
and he goes yeah now i know exactly what
you mean it's it's
it's a different thing you know being a
good gym fighter doesn't mean anything
you you know these guys in the gym they
work circles around the world champions
but once you put them under pressure
they can't do it you know
you need to can once you can control
that i saw it for years in the comedy
game oh yeah i saw this switch from us
from uh city to los angeles
i saw it once or twice a month what
happened to that guy
he cracked at the improv yep he got in
the plane and went back to whatever let
me do some shout outs
it's crazy how that goes pressure guys
russian impression is real there's
everything especially stand up coming
well i want to thank everybody who
downloaded
the new special on
csotv.com thank you very much
from the bottom of my heart you guys
know who you are and i love you to that
arse warrior david knott
the fire clown ookie spooky looking good
one by one podcast
my man mike my man matt balthazar
running [ __ ] sunday sabbath
andrew nodow over there and [ __ ]
nayak running things
[ __ ] genius
and ray majewski i love you [ __ ]
some nice words from joey yeah these
guys know i love it and stuff like that
now do you have some available now on
the webcast yeah yeah we we have them
back again you know the results are
crazy just try it 30 repetitions in the
morning breathing exercises with screen
10 that's it wait till i come out with
all my uh medical journals people gonna
freak out i mean we've got four olympic
gold medalist training on it and that's
like i said including usain bolt so
we're doing something good right here
and now
hopefully we can make it into a medical
device hey if you want to really uh give
this a shot go to a i go to
two
trainer with a capital t
trainer.com is that it 02 trainer o2
training two trainers
800 milligrams
but was it
812 on it way more than 800.
joey
i am your father
i would do it every morning i drive to
the to the ocean to swim there do crazy
exercises in the car do you always have
the nose plug on
no i don't i just don't breathe in
through my nose that's what i don't like
because that's the habit i got it yeah
but
somebody told me you know but but then
i'm cheating i said then you're cheating
the person the one person in the world
that you should never cheat yourself
so just don't breathe in through your
nose that's it
lee what kind of changes you're going
through tonight
answer me you're sweating
you're wiping your forehead what
happened talking no i'm hot i'm fine
though let's go through some deep
changes
medium changes you know i love you i
ain't gonna say that would you hear
voices
oh only in spanish
oh no i don't know no i
feel funny
it's hard i felt that
as long as you're hot you have me
nervous there for a second i know you're
going some deep
deep
deep deep deep [ __ ] changes
tonight
so i just want you to be alright when we
call the hospital well let's still got
another three or four more red stars for
us we're going to open up the weed big
we say it's over there absolutely no one
gives a frenchman's [ __ ]
anymore you understand me
first off uh
this company made me a suit and i never
went down there to pick it up
so i got to go down there this week i
got to go down there maybe thursday i'm
going to call to go tomorrow
i promise you because it was a
tremendous experience okay i don't know
if you guys wear suits or not but it's
the holidays plus you might have to go
to court plus you might get a dui plus
you might have to go to a [ __ ]
wedding
excuse me plus plus plus plus plus
[ __ ] you gotta get a suit even my
goomba lee over here didn't have a suit
i talked him into it now he's got a suit
for every [ __ ] occasion because you
you know there's times you can dress
like a bum and there's times you need to
dazzle [ __ ] they can't see you
listen you don't want to see
you don't want them to see you coming
stop it
stop it
anyway that's nice yeah you don't want
people to see you coming you want to
[ __ ] show up looking something good
conor mcgregor like today a [ __ ]
church i wore a nice suit why because i
wanted to impress my [ __ ] daughter
not to impress those [ __ ] yokels
anyway conor mcgregor looks great in
suits suits are great now was it made to
measure suit not really but the guy put
the [ __ ] finishing touches on it
looks okay i don't know what you guys
know
what a [ __ ] measured suit feels like
compared to a generic off the rack suit
okay but i know
one thing i do know about my personal
experience with indochina okay i went
down there they measured me up
they showed me the different materials
it was something
out of this world you know why because
indochino is one of the largest made to
measure menswear brands that make it
easy for men to get great fitting high
quality suits and shirts at an
incredible price all right here's how it
works excuse me you go to indochino.com
or drop by one of their nine north
american showrooms you pick from
hundreds of fabrics and patterns okay i
did it right down there on beverly hills
you sh you choose your customizations
from lapels to pleats to jacket linings
to more you submit your body
measurements you kick back relax
and get ready to step into the best most
stylish suit you've ever worn in just
four weeks you understand me this week
my listeners can get any premium indo
chino suit for just 389 at
indochino.com when entering church
c-h-u-r-c-h you don't want to show up at
grandma's wearing that stupid [ __ ]
gray shirt again do you you want to show
up bang it with a [ __ ] suit whatever
anyway do yourself a favor it's the
holidays what i'm gonna do is this
that's fit 389 is basically 50 off the
regular price for a made to measure
premium suit plus
shipping is free who's better than uncle
joey that's
indochino.com
promo code church
c-h-u-r-c-h for any premium suit for
just 389 with free shipping indochino
also has amazing holiday deals right now
on their shirts pants and other products
too you'll never have to worry about
looking like a bum with badly fitting
suits or expensive trips to the tailor
again
get ready to look like a million dollars
all right again go to indo
chino
dot com slash joey i'm gonna take your
character
oh
slash
indochino.com
we're gonna take good care of you you
know who's gonna take your carrier
listen people let's get the ball going
okay you're what 12 13 days away from
christmas maybe what what's today's date
it's the 11th the 11th all right
tomorrow tomorrow's monday that's the
12th so in reality
you got 12 maybe 11 days 13 days to pick
up a check paycheck okay
how are you going to put it together
what are you going to do go dance at a
bar
you can barely walk people throw apples
at you and [ __ ] what are you gonna do
guys what are you gonna do walk around
and go down and stand online to get
picked and work the holidays are ten
days away even if you get picked you're
gonna get a [ __ ] check in the mail
nothing bothers me more than they're
checking the mail around the holidays
after it's 10th it's all about cash and
dollar i got an idea for you all right
i'm going to tell you a smart way to
earn extra money and get 500 bonuses
driving with lyft okay listen you're in
between jobs and you're looking to earn
some extra money you're looking to put
some money away
for college right you're going back to
school yourself you want to get another
degree or your first one you're writing
the next great american novel and
looking for explanation uh inspiration
you know you're someone who loves to
drive you're someone who just plain
loves people if any of these things fit
you
lyft is the way for you to go all right
here's what they got
they got other ride sharing apps out
there but lyft treats that drive is
right it's a flexible way to make money
anytime from nearly anywhere all you
need is a car lyft drivers can make up
to 35 an hour and getting started is
just a tap away that means you could be
driving tomorrow you can drive mornings
you can drive nights you can drive
weekends you can flip into a driver mode
and start making money plus lyft drivers
can earn tips right through the app
those app ads let me tell you something
those add up real fast and you don't
have to wait days or weeks to get paid
this is what i'm talking about the
holidays are coming you can cash out
instantly once you've made
fifty dollars thanks to express pay all
right driving with lyft is super
flexible listen you're an insomniac what
are you gonna go sit down
i watched a bunch of movies i look
listen get the [ __ ] car you get out
there you earn whatever it's better than
sitting there and watching tv like a
momo this is flexible as can be sign up
today at lyft.com
joey again
right now lyft has a special offer for
all our listeners
you get 500 all right
500
new driver bonus
after you complete 100 rides in 30 days
you can do that
standing on your head okay go to
lyft.com
joey today and you can start making
extra money and get your 500
new driver bonus today limited time only
get your action together restrictions
apply but the party starts right now all
right and also
listen you're looking for the holiday
gift you're sitting there scratching
your ass going
what am i gonna get for this guy
i just started dating him
we had sex a few times
and after i got up i noticed there was a
weird odor in the room what am i gonna
get this guy oh [ __ ]
hellotushy.com [ __ ]
i started dating this girl
and she's tremendous but every time she
leaves the house
my dog won't stop sneezing it smells
like rotten ass
hellotushy.com bishops
bidets are back devices that spray
your butt clean with water i grew up
with a bidet in my house and i gotta
tell you some it was tremendous well
guess what thanks to tushy sleep midday
that clips onto your existing toilet and
sprays your butt completely clean with
fresh water to get your muffler
sparkling all right listen so you're not
sitting there on bacteria causing
hemorrhoids yeast infections and just
plain old rotten ass listen why do this
why sit there like a mook
[ __ ] eight hours a day your asshole's
rotting to death hell no you go to your
bathroom you do what you gotta do you
turn the bidet on and guess what
your life becomes a [ __ ] reality it's
a dream that's what big days to you they
give you confidence they wash your butt
they wash the back of your scrotum you
could dip your helmet in there whatever
the hell you got to do hello she's going
to save the day [ __ ] and guess what
hello tushy is a tremendous
[ __ ] christmas gift how's that
one for you you're confused you don't
know what to get them
everybody needs a clean [ __ ] am i
lying
everybody needs a clean [ __ ] that's
why i tell you what you're gonna do
you're gonna go to hellotushy.com right
now
and on the way out you get 10 off by
putting
church
c-h-u-r-c-h listen but days are better
for the environment anyway there's no
paper more trees okay if this tushy only
requires one pint of water plus you have
a 60-day
guarantee okay
what are you going to do you're going to
keep walking around with that rotten
[ __ ] muffler
go to hellotushy.com right now and put
in church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off merry
christmas to you [ __ ] that's
the [ __ ] uh stocking stuffer here
anyway i want to thank lyft go to lyft
right now
lyft.com and get a [ __ ] job don't
make me tell you again
hellotushy.com slash church
and and the best part about lyft is is
you're making money on those 100 rides
so you're making an extra 500 but you're
making a ton of money on those hundred
rides listen guys get it together all
right i just gave you you're broke
you're sitting there with your thumb up
your ass where'd you buy that car for a
look at it
i got a nice car well now what are you
gonna do with it you got nobody to bang
in there what do you gotta go where they
got to go lib.com correct that's it
live.com slash joey
and what's the other one chu indochino
indochino
chino.com i love you [ __ ] see
you guys tues wednesday morning on it
too and we want to thank on the doctrine
right now another tremendous holiday
stuffer go to honor right now and press
in church bam c-h-u-r-c-h
get 10 off shipped directly to the house
on supplements only i love you guys see
you [ __ ] wednesday morning stay
black
you're one crazy guy my friend
[Music]
[Music]
it's all the same
only the names will change
[Music]
where the faces are so cold
just to get back home
[Music]
alive
[Music]
[Music]
that you drink
[Music]
morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
completely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you